hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast
and I'm just checking in on you
just seeing how you're doing I'm not
going to yell because if I do
this never-ending
and cough man
saw a doctor I'm on an antibiotic I got
testificovid
um it's just one of those things you're
gonna have to ride it out you're just
gonna have to ride it out
um oh Billy football
Oh Billy World Cup I actually watched
the USA
versus uh Iran
I watched the whole [ __ ] why miss the
first 10 minutes
I taped it I watched it you know what's
great about taping World Cup games in
America you don't have to worry about
any of your friends ruining the results
um so I watched this game
and the USA is just dominating the
entire first half it looks like Iran
shouldn't even be out there they can't
even touch the ball we played the whole
[ __ ] first half in their end
and then finally
we score a goal I was getting nervous I
was like this is like hockey we're
totally dominating but we're not putting
a Biscuit in a basket there and then
what happens is the other team just
[ __ ] gets it and then scores a goal
and it's super deflating so I was
worried that that's that that is what
was going to happen
but um
we finally ended up scoring a goal
and of course the guy who scored the
goal ended up getting hurt when he
scored
um
I mean he laid on the ground like he got
hit by a [ __ ] car
um
and uh I don't understand why they don't
wear pads in soccer you know what I mean
or get tougher people to play soccer
one of Something's Gotta [ __ ] give
like why don't you wear some shin guards
every [ __ ] time a guy runs down the
field some guy slides in
his foot hits his shin and then the guy
rolls around on the ground this is what
kills me like it's the first time he
ever got kicked in the shin
like at what point do you toughen up and
be like I'm a soccer player I'm used to
getting kicked in the shin
all right hey I ain't saying I'm not
saying I'm no tough guy I don't like
getting kicked in the shin either but
like I'm not on [ __ ] TV
I can tell you this if I got kicked in
the shin and it really [ __ ] hurt I
would be doing everything I could to get
on my feet as quickly as possible
because I would not want to be rolling
around in pain while it's being filmed
on television
and here's another thing you watch the
[ __ ] UFC these [ __ ] guys
kick another [ __ ] man in the shin
with their shin and they keep fighting
so like either get some [ __ ] pads
are toughen the [ __ ] up
Jesus Christ with the extra time
dude that guy who scored the goal for
[ __ ] you know you would have thought
he'd like like a [ __ ] truck hit him
he was just on the ground and on the
ground and nobody could celebrate with
him because he was having his little
moment right
now I kicked the ball in his [ __ ]
knee sliding to me ribs
um
I will say though a lot of times I'm
like what the [ __ ] is that guy rolling
around the ground he didn't even get hit
and then they show in slow motion it's
like oh yeah he did he did but like I
swear to God like
their threshold for pain doesn't go up
after a while
I mean no offense rest of the world but
American football I mean guys play with
like [ __ ] dislocated shoulders
you know everything from turf toe to
concussions they play through it
I I I don't understand it I really don't
um so anyway I we go to watch the second
half and I'm like this is like and we
need to win this game to advance
you know how funny it would be if the
USA actually won the World Cup
and then they'd have a championship
parade that looked like a WNBA
Championship parade
like i s like I don't think anybody
would like watch it until they got into
like the final
and then the whole time would just be
asking questions like the whole time
like going like
so like why why are they still playing
oh because there's extra time
extra time for what oh cause that guy
was rolling around holding on to his
[ __ ] butt cheek for [ __ ] 10
minutes
well how much extra time is there nobody
knows only only the ref knows but when
people start whistling that means
they're getting annoyed
so anyway the uh I'm just [ __ ] with
you guys I actually enjoyed watching the
game but like the [ __ ]
the lack of manhood I mean women's
soccer is better
they pop up way quicker
oh wait did they get shin pads
um anyway so we go I go to watch the
second half of this [ __ ]
um
match
and it's a tale of two games all of a
sudden
Iran comes out
and we can't even keep hold of the ball
and I'm watching the web we're playing
I'm like you got to be [ __ ] [ __ ]
me we're now playing not to lose and I
watched 50 minutes 51 minutes the whole
second half
because of of injury time or whatever
watching our team in a [ __ ] prevent
defense the number one thing I can't
[ __ ] stand but they actually were
playing defense they started playing to
not lose
and um
it was so [ __ ] annoying I almost
started rooting for Iran
you know I'm like well wouldn't it be
great if I ran one and then knocked us
out and then I wouldn't have to watch
more of this
um
sorry
anyway
so we won
one to nothing and when I tell you
when we won that game I heard no screams
of joy from my neighbors nothing it was
just dead silence
on my street
it just is what it is
um speaking of sports the people don't
pay attention to enough in America uh
the NHL the Boston Bruins are 19-3 their
best start ever was in the 1930s at 19
and two
we beat the Tampa Bay Lightning I think
for the second time this year and they
absolutely have owned us
you know
for I feel the better part of a goddamn
like six seven seasons
so I'm trying not to get too excited and
it's not even December
but uh
they're playing great and and Alexander
Ovechkin just passed Wayne Gretzky for
most goals on the road
I mean it's insane how he just sort of
quietly has snuck up on Wayne Gretzky
and during this era too
you know with the giant goalie pads and
everybody in the butterfly and the
left-wing lock and all of that [ __ ] that
it looks like if he stays healthy he's
gonna pass Wayne Gretzky which never in
a million years seem possible
I think for all-time goals
I don't know about a cyst I mean Gretzky
has almost 2 000 assists I don't think
Ovechkin has that
so anyway I'm in
I've been in a grouchy mood for a few
weeks because
um you know your health is everything
um
so anyway I'm dropping my daughter off
at school today
and uh as I'm driving down this street
I see like 40 [ __ ] douchebags
out in front of this coffee shop or
something all with their their you know
Tour de France gear on
and I just looked and I was like oh God
the douchebags are out right
I mean do you realize like the level of
[ __ ] [ __ ] you have to be
if you do that
first of all if you can't just you know
buy a bicycle and put on some [ __ ]
Rocky Balboa gray sweatshirt gray
sweatpants and just get on the [ __ ]
bike the fact that you got to go out and
buy that stupid [ __ ] outfit with
those goddamn dance slippers do you
really have to clip your feet in
to ride around a neighborhood
um
I mean you can do this and everything do
you really have to go to an NFL game you
know wearing an official jersey with
[ __ ] [ __ ] under your eyes like you're
gonna [ __ ] start catching punts on
special teams you know oh Billy Grandpa
grumpy freckled [ __ ] is in full effect
today
so I'm looking at them and I'm just
thinking like just like
you know
if ever like a rogue wave could just
come along and sweep 40 people out into
the ocean that you never saw again
wouldn't that be great
I mean that would just just 40 for 40.
you're talking like only Joe DiMaggio 56
game hitting streak it was the only
thing Mother Nature could [ __ ] with if
she just had a rogue wave come Inland
and just wash a group of 40 cyclists
out into the ocean with their bikes and
their stupid outfits
wouldn't that be just tremendous
do you realize the level of [ __ ] you
have to be that you don't feel like
you can't really feel like you're
getting a workout unless you
inconvenience a thousand strangers
you know what I mean like I just don't
understand like
there is I like riding a bike
sure we all do there is no [ __ ] way I
would ever ride a bike out in the street
with 40 of my friends knowing that
everyone in a car is absolutely [ __ ]
livid because we've created our own
[ __ ] traffic jam
in the city of Los Angeles that is
beyond congested to begin with but these
people have no problem with it like I'm
telling you
if any of them put that in their dating
profile what is it swipe left is that
what you guys say you can't [ __ ] date
that
here's another one ah geez I'm on a roll
here
I'm coming back
right I'm coming back
I'm coming back I'm coming back from
dropping my daughter off from school
and I come up over the hill and lo and
behold there's this jogger sprinting
in the street coming right at me like a
third of the way we like playing chicken
and I'm like I'm not [ __ ] moving
there's a sidewalk
you [ __ ] [ __ ] right it's the last
second he sort of runs on the other what
the [ __ ] he was doing he looked like
he's not like the NFL combine
it's another group of people oh if I was
a dictator
why let me why don't I just ask instead
of being a douche joggers why don't you
run on the sidewalk
huh well I don't want to be
inconvenienced it's an uneven surface
and there's women pushing their babies
down the foot they join a [ __ ] gym
you gotta run out of the [ __ ] street
now I have to stop and wait you know to
with the [ __ ] another Lane is clear
[ __ ] unbelievable
there's literally miles of [ __ ]
hard surface that you can jog on down
the [ __ ] L.A River it's why they have
it and these [ __ ] [ __ ]
run right down the street the third of
the way out so you have to slow down
look you know make sure nobody's coming
on the other side of the street to make
sure everybody's passing these [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude
I'm telling you right now this is what
kills me
is that some woman
is going to fall in love with that guy
and have kids with them and then she's
going to have the [ __ ] nerve
to sit there and talk about how he's
distant how he's [ __ ] selfish and
he's not involved with their children
and all of her friends are going to sit
there and be like Oh Maggie I feel so
bad for you if only there was a sign
there was a sign Maggie he runs in the
[ __ ] Street against traffic
sorry
all right
so anyway
this is a uh this is the end of the
month here
Oh Billy freckles
Oh Billy bull Jangles the end of the
month um
and this is my new thing so I'm actually
starting today
because why not and I might actually go
15 days but my new thing is the first 10
days
of every month
um
I sort of like detox from uh
whatever has a hold of me and right now
nothing has a hold of me
except uh
I think maybe coffee does I just like
drinking coffee because it makes me not
smoke cigars
so I haven't had a cigar since October
really have no desire to have one
I haven't had any soda sense because you
know what I I stopped the end of October
and then went the first 10 days in
November and then I didn't want one
and I was also thinking I got all this
root beer and [ __ ] downstairs and I'm
just like
I don't want to drink that [ __ ] like
because it's it's not
you know I don't have any sugar in me so
that's when you look at a cake
with your rational brain
you know or a cookie going like why the
[ __ ] would I eat that
and you know what's amazing when you
don't have sugar for like 10 days the
second you have something that has any
sugar in it you [ __ ]
your face puckers up like you bit into a
lemon
so um
I don't know I think I'm all right with
my uh
my coffee [ __ ] because it you know I
think it's the worst thing that I do is
you know I have a couple of coffees each
day I don't think it's that bad
but
um
but anyway I just don't like that whole
having to quit [ __ ] so
I feel like if I just go the first 10
days of every month
and I kind of just reset
then no matter how nuts I get in the
final 15 20 days
you know I know it's not going to get
too out of control because I'm going to
stop again
and then also I find when I come off
those 10 days
that I really don't
want to indulge in whatever I was
indulging in
really for about 15 days so it's only
half the month
that's not bad right
I don't know
I still don't think that they've done
enough research on all of this [ __ ]
because I'm I'm fascinated with like I
feel like I've become more
um
addictive
like something happened that last time
when my drinking alcohol got out of
control
that now I just have like I kind of
if I do something I just I think I would
always like that but never to this
[ __ ] level
you know what I mean
I mean who gets a cappuccino and a
double espresso it's literally I'm
recreating a beer and a shot
here's another thing too
is I can drink that in the afternoon and
be in bed and go to sleep by nine like I
don't even know I I just I think you
should just keep pounding the waters
if you're young and listening to this
this is what happens
this is what happens to you I don't
think they like you always get excited I
remember as a kid being like man I can't
wait to move out
then do whatever the [ __ ] I want to do
man watch what I want to watch
go out and come on whenever the [ __ ] I
feel like like no one ever tells you
know what sucks about being an adult is
you have to kind of you have to become
your own parent
and then it take a lot of people like
myself it takes you decades
to learn how to take care of yourself
like hey man you know what maybe
maybe don't eat that maybe don't drink
another one maybe uh maybe stay in
tonight
you know you know what we need Bill we
need a nice
eight hours sleep how about that you
know
that took me till about I don't know 52
to learn how to do that
I'll tell you all of these [ __ ] nerds
all you young people you look at these
kids who are [ __ ] nerds
you know as long as they're not on some
in-cell website you know
whatever the [ __ ] they're doing like
they they're doing it right you know
they go home
you know they watch their space show
they play some video games well then
they're up all night aren't they
yeah there's no reason to glorify nerds
any more than they already are right
oh they always feel like they're like
these [ __ ] harmless people
you know what's the worst
is a nerd that gets power
okay everybody's going to pay for it
everybody's going to pay for every time
he got [ __ ] hung by a door handle
from his [ __ ] underwear everybody's
gonna pay for the fact that the pretty
girls never looked at him everybody's
going to pay for the fact that he
doesn't know how to throw a catch
you're all gonna like vengeance
Vengeance these little [ __ ]
Bookworm trolls all of a sudden they
they create an app
they do something and where are they
all these harmless trolls they're right
down at the titty bar
right being a [ __ ] creep
I'm just making all of this [ __ ] up
um
anyway uh
so I haven't been to the gym in like
[ __ ] three weeks because I don't
wanna
I wanna get over this coffin I'm also
not going to go down there and give
somebody whatever the [ __ ] this is
but
[Music]
um
I have been flying a little bit
I had a nice flight the other day
um
I went up and uh
you know I pre-flighted the thing
brought her out
and I was sitting there and it was like
uh nice visibility like early in the day
it was like uh
what do they call it uh
it wasn't quite IFR
I don't know what the [ __ ] they call it
it's when it shows up and it's like blue
special VFR
whatever the [ __ ] it was
so um I was waiting for that [ __ ] to
burn off and then I Get Ready To Fly
and um
you know I want to go up the coast of
Malibu
so I'm checking out uh Santa Monica's
you know weather and [ __ ] and I see that
it looks all right but I'm kind of
looking out to the coast and it looks
like a little cloudy or whatever
and I know that I'm going to be flying
up the coast
of Malibu with the Santa Monica
Mountains and this one of those deals
where as long as you're on the coast
it's all right but when you want to fly
up and over the mountains if the clouds
are low enough you know you can't get
over because they're meeting the top of
the mountains
[Music]
um
so I kind of got to deal with all of
that
you know because it was definitely
spots where I could poke through and
everything
and but then I was always thinking like
dude at the end of the day it's a
helicopter I can just set it down if I
have a [ __ ] problem I can turn around
I can go back I can keep going up the
coast and go up Oxnard and just come in
that way I get plenty of fuel
everything's fine it's like a really
good like
um
like confidence Builder I flew great
you know on the radio and all of that
everything was fine
and um
I don't know it was just like a great
flight and I have like a buddy of mine's
coming out to California it's the flight
I want to take them on so I was making
sure it's a really cool flight
um come out of Burbank
you do like a a fly over the Rose Bowl
you know left orbit I keep it at 70
knots just in case I have an engine
failure I know exactly where I'm gonna
put it uh then you go down the 110 you
go over Dodger Stadium do an orbit of
that you do an orbit around downtown up
to the observatory the Hollywood sign
the Hollywood Bowl
Capital Records you go by that you can't
really even see it anymore because they
[ __ ] built these two goddamn
buildings right around it
um
then I go right down sunset
which is really cool
uh and then there's a couple of these
classic old like houses I look at
um
in Beverly Hills one of them is like the
Doheny mansion and then the other one is
that classic one that they Godfather 2
and JFK and Jackie Kennedy had their uh
honeymoon there and The Bodyguard I
think they shot that there Beverly Hills
Hotel then you just out then you're up
go up [ __ ] Malibu Malibu Beach pier
and all of that [ __ ] come back up and
over and you go back into Burbank it's a
[ __ ] grave oh Ronald Reagan Library
right gotta see that
um
that's something I'm going to start
going to when I'm on the road
presidential libraries
you know I find those you know first of
all I thought everybody had one
they they don't there's only like 15 of
them I've been to the Richard Nixon
I've been to the Ronald Reagan
and I've been to the uh
the JFK one
like 40 years ago when it first [ __ ]
came out
um I don't know why I never think to go
to then
um
the Reagan one was probably the best one
they all have something cool like I
remember the Nixon one in California we
went to that and that one had like one
of those [ __ ] like presidential
limousines there
had some old car outside his house where
he grew up
um maybe that's what it was maybe it's
just his house maybe it wasn't the
library
um and then the Reagan one is cool
because they actually have the Air Force
One plane
in the [ __ ] thing and you can get on
it
and go right by the seat and look at the
phone
where Reagan talked to Gorbachev
it's pretty good you know even if you're
a liberal I think you can go in there
and just sort of
you know
I mean I would rather do that than that
stupid time we went to the [ __ ] the
history of the popes
whatever the [ __ ] that was Sistine
Chapel oh my God
I cannot stress enough if you go to that
there's a right turn and a left turn and
you want to go on the shorter one that
takes you right to the the painted
ceiling you don't want to go the long
way that's where we went where they had
every stupid [ __ ] chalice
in in Silver Spoon that every [ __ ]
one of these murderous [ __ ]
murderers
[ __ ] murderers it's the weirdest
it's the weirdest [ __ ] thing
you know
at least that's how I looked at it and
then I remember all of a sudden they
would be having like uh
they were having like a mass and for
like all of these Catholic people it's
just [ __ ] unbelievable thing if they
go into the Vatican City
and attend a mass there
which just blows my mind considering
what that organization has done
um
I mean talk about shaking off a [ __ ]
scandal
you know some people they have like a
little Scandal and it just takes them
out and then other people you see
something you're like oh man they're
never going to recover from that and
they just walk away like nothing
happened
that would be the Catholic Church
my God
murders pedophilia
in business with the Nazis I mean just
write down if there's a dude they're
like the USC of religions
where like a
where buddy of mine was always said was
saying you know if there's some sort of
Scandal going on
in in college sports and there's more
than one University involved USC is
going to be one of those universities
I mean it's just a I mean you got to
admit even as a USC fit it's a filthy
organization that they're running down
there I mean it's just [ __ ] it's the
Dukes of Hazzard boss hug they got fake
fire hydrants they got people [ __ ]
photoshopping heads on to [ __ ] other
people Jeffrey Dahmer [ __ ] you know to
get like a scholarship
what I did love about all of those kids
though
that fake their way into schools
was you would think that you would get
exposed the second you got there that
you weren't smart enough to be there but
all of them seemed to handle the
curriculum no problem so it's really
you know because at the end of the day
like geometry is geometry
right two plus two is four
you know cat is spelled c-a-t so I mean
I think it's all
it really is so if you're a young person
man just [ __ ] Crush High School
and then you should be all right once
you get into your school
or you go the other way
you don't do well in high school and
then you go to like a community college
right and then like delivering [ __ ]
dominoes
you can you can pay for your your
tuition for the first two years you do
great there then you transfer to the
more expensive School you get the same
degree as somebody else for half the
price you come in as a junior
right
take it from me I went to summer school
every [ __ ] year of high school not
every year freshman year Junior should
have gone senior year
but I was like what's the [ __ ] point
and should have gone sophomore year but
my teacher hooked me up with a D minus
um there those are my confessions all
right somewhere in there uh where are
you right now we're gonna do the uh
we're gonna do the advertisement all
right everybody now it's time for the
advertising reach
um with my freaking cough here I'm gonna
do the best I can look who it is
everybody it's so zip
recruiter
are you hiring
what type of role are you hiring for
maybe you need to hire someone to wear
many hats
the iron a clown which can be
challenging or you might have a simple
position to fill fries
um but it takes forever to find someone
who's a great fit for your company
whether you need to hire a new civil
engineer in New York a pediatric nurse
in Nebraska or an attorney in Colorado
or even a mascot in Missouri I knew one
state was going to get [ __ ] on someone's
going to be a simple State OH ZIP down
can help you find qualified candidates
fast and now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
from accountants to zoologists and
everything in between zip
matching technology finds people with
the right experience for your job and
presents them to you
then you can invite your top choices to
apply it's so effective that four to
five employers who post on zip
them up get a quality candidate within
the first day try it now for free at
this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
once again that's ziprecruiter.com
it's a recruiter
the smartest way to hire
all right we got one more here people
yeah look who it is it's simply safe
you know if you thought about securing
your home with home security but have
been putting it off you want to listen
up yeah especially with that cocaine
bear out there I don't think I've seen
that movie trailer
uh right now my listeners can order the
number one rated Simply Safe home
security system for 50 off this is their
biggest offer of the year and you won't
want to miss it simply safe was named
the best home security system of 2022 by
U.S news and World Report a third year
in a row it's a freaking Dynasty in an
emergency 24 7 Professional monitoring
agents use fast protect TM technology
exclusively from SimpliSafe to capture
critical evidence and verify the threat
is real so you can get priority police
response Simply Safe is whole is whole
home security with Advanced sensors for
every room window and door HD security
cameras for inside and out smarter ways
to detect motion that alert you only
when a threat is real and even Hazard
sensors that detect fires floods and
other threats to your home 24 7
Professional monitoring Services cost
under a dollar a day less than half the
price of adt's traditional professional
installed system with top-rated Simply
Safe app stay in complete control of
your system anytime anywhere arm or
disarm unlock for a guest access your
cameras or adjust system settings don't
miss your chance for massive savings on
my favorite security system get 50 off
any new system at simplysafe.com this is
their biggest discount of the year
that's simplysafe.com
there's no safe like SimpliSafe all
right that's the Thursday podcast thank
you for listening please listen to the
music the great Andrew females will pick
out and then we'll have a bonus episode
of the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast have a
great weekend yeah [ __ ]
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday
uh December 1st
2014 the final month of 2014.
you know did you have a good one
you didn't well it's too late
actually it isn't too late you can get
Dia [ __ ] your two-minute offense
you know the final [ __ ] month of the
year you could have [ __ ] up this
entire year and you could bring it all
home
all those disgusted looks you got from
your family members
over the Thanksgiving weekend you could
turn it all around in the final you got
31 days
the most possible days you can get
in the [ __ ] white man's calendar I
don't know how it works over there in
the Chinese calendar or the Native
American calendar
but all you get in our world is 31 days
that's it
all right you get 31 [ __ ] days to
turn it around what are you gonna do huh
you're going to go out and go shovel the
[ __ ] driveway
what are you gonna do to make it up oh
gives a [ __ ] right at this point at this
point you kind of tap out right you're
just like I'm losing on points I didn't
get knocked out I'm just gonna hang on
for the final [ __ ] three minutes and
uh whatever I'll live to fight another
day it starts in January
starts January dude I'm gonna join a gym
I'm gonna quit smoking I'm gonna dump
this broad I'm gonna [ __ ] get a
better lubricant when I jerk off you
make all those promises to yourself
right
and then you end up once again looking
back on a year
right on December 1st going what the
[ __ ] happened I'm another year older
what did I do you know what you did you
got no stick-to-itiness I can't even say
that word stick-to-itiveness
just pick one you know I'm gonna try to
stop watching porno
I've already gone like four or five days
and uh
I gotta tell you I don't miss it I don't
miss it although I am kind of confused
with some of this [ __ ] like uh Kim
Kardashian's uh greased up ass
that she had there whatever lubed up
[ __ ] uh whatever she did backed into
a mister however they got it to shine
you know
like I what the [ __ ] was the big deal
you can see that uh like for free all
over the Internet so then all of a
sudden her ass is on the internet and
then everybody said and I hate this
[ __ ] expression
started like a week ago now every
douchebag on the planet has said it said
it broke the internet
yo you grease up your ass that [ __ ]
gonna break the internet [ __ ]
stupid it's you could you could see
a million asses right but it's not her
ass how do you even know it was her ass
with Photoshop these days you know what
I mean
it is a bunch of beautiful big ass
[ __ ] out there they could have
[ __ ] put her little puppet head right
on the top of it
you know
you got no [ __ ] clue got no clue
whose asset is when you went out there
and broke the unit what does that mean
you couldn't download it
there was so many people downloading it
uh there's anything I can't stand it's
excitement about nothing you know
all the real [ __ ] stuff I was almost
I almost just said that's how arrogant I
am I almost just said all the real [ __ ]
that's going on out there
in other words what Bill the [ __ ] that's
just bugging you that you feel everybody
else should pay attention to you
myopic jackass I'm sorry happy holidays
um
speaking of myopic and that type of
stuff that whole uh Ferguson Trial there
uh Ferguson uh uh Missouri trial
you know I I didn't I didn't pay
attention to it and uh you know it's the
same old story
same old story and it always plays out
the same way and then a bunch of people
who weren't there emphatically tell you
what happened
and this one like all of them it's two
sides
and it's a completely different story
and you just sit there watching these
people screaming at each other none of
whom were there and then some mediators
sitting in the middle never going hey
hey guys guys neither one of you were
there
according to the information that I
decided to pay attention to my argument
is correct
um I'm gonna go out on a limb here and
I'm going to say they were both full of
[ __ ] on both sides everybody's lying
once it goes to court everybody's
[ __ ] lying you're trying to build up
your case because you know they're gonna
lie
right so you got to build that you gotta
you gotta stack up the cupcakes on your
side of the case you just gotta Build It
Up
he had his back to him I do but he had
his back his hands were up and he had
his shirt a shirt on that said Don't
Shoot Me and then the other side he ran
at me I gotta go he had a sickle and he
was throbbing at the mouth and he said I
hate white people
and you sit there and you watch this
[ __ ] right
split screen is too [ __ ] morons
screaming each other and at the end in
the end of all of those [ __ ] debates
you get nowhere
nothing sold nothing's resolved you
don't have any more information than you
did all you did was just sit there and
watch two [ __ ] people yell at each
other
so what I choose to do
is to not watch it sit at home and stare
at my balls
you know I'm not saying you have to do
that but that's how I handle those big
cases
if you don't have balls you know just
Crick your neck a little further and
look at your own [ __ ] hoo-ha sorry
I'm in a great mood man I had an I had a
long needed four-day [ __ ] weekend
I had a great Thanksgiving I had chicken
instead of turkey because my kitchen is
a [ __ ] disaster because it's still
not fixed
you know
um I am trying so hard not to say out
loud that I hate my [ __ ] house but I
just you know something else you know my
car my Prius is getting old and I want
to go out and get something nice but my
driveway is [ __ ] up
my driveway is like uh
it goes up and then down like the top of
a mountain or the top of a house if you
look at the side of it looking at the
roof you know so the snow slides down it
does that because on one side we got
water coming down a hill and they don't
want it to go down my driveway so they
built this [ __ ] Peak
so even my [ __ ] Prius will bottom out
if I get too far to the left on the
driveway so now I want to get something
fast and you know the deal it's got to
be low to the ground so you can dive
into the [ __ ] corners
um so there's no way that's gonna make
it so now what I have to do is I gotta
have them build up the back side of it
my driveway make that higher so it's not
such a drastic dip
when you go on the other side you know
and who knows maybe even the [ __ ]
nose is going to scrape as I tried again
I just can't [ __ ] win with this
[ __ ] house not to mention
right
the defense there all the wood is
[ __ ] rotted out
what was that game you played when you
were a kid
the Wonder Ball
the Wonder ball goes round and round
to something something you abound and if
you do then you are out o u t out hey
Ernie sit the [ __ ] down right isn't that
how it went
I I basically lost that game except the
Wonder Ball was the house that I bought
for a hundred [ __ ] years people own
this house
Jackie Robinson broke the color barrier
Kennedy got shot Nixon is impeached
you're left with the house
yeah that's what happened to me
galvanized pipe cloth [ __ ] wires
rotted out wood
[ __ ]
water brought off the roof into the
house and out the front through rotted
out pipes which started this whole
[ __ ] Fiasco I had rat turds in the
wall downstairs
this house has been waiting for a
complete freckled jerk off like me to
buy it
okay so I would go out and fix the
[ __ ] thing right
this house is going to have another
hundred years it's going to get another
100 years out of it because I'm going to
own this [ __ ] thing okay and
everybody else who owns this house is
gonna have a big [ __ ] grin in their
face for like the first 70 or so years
all right
and do you think those sons of [ __ ]
in the future
are going to thank me
I swear to God
at some point all right when I get
when I feel like I only have a week left
to live I'm going to say the address of
where the [ __ ] I live
so maybe somebody will listen to this
thing in the future
you know
stick a Miller Light on my [ __ ]
headstone
Middle Light sorry Miller High Life
um anyway
so this is the Monday morning podcast uh
welcome I hope you guys had a Happy
Thanksgiving
um
I I had a [ __ ] great one man and uh
oh you know what I wanted to do
actually even though you know that guy
I've been hyping for like the last like
year year and a half
on my uh on my Twitter account I keep
posting his videos he's a rust of the
wrestler a wrestler
the uh the one-man Thrill Ride Jimmy
Preston the one man threw it right
like an absolute Savage that guy I
[ __ ] love that guy I think he's a
he's a [ __ ] star and I don't
understand why he's not in the WWE yet
he's got all he's got it all he's got
the looks
he's got the dedication and he [ __ ]
kills it on the microphone so uh anytime
you post a video I try and re retweet it
and he sent out a Happy Thanksgiving one
he gave uh he gave me a little shout out
made
my [ __ ] weekend and then like a
douche I go to retweet it and I
retweeted it to his fake one of the
other person pretending to be him
I'm trying to scroll here to find it if
you guys want to follow the guy the
guy's [ __ ] hilarious
um ah Jesus Christ of course I can't
find the [ __ ] thing come on Bill
all I'm doing is seeing all the [ __ ]
that I retweeted I retweeted this
classic picture
um it said Iceberg with red and black
paint on it believed to be the iceberg
that that sank the Titanic and some
[ __ ] writes back um it actually hit
the [ __ ]
Titanic underneath the water line
and he's like you ever hear that
expression tip of the iceberg I mean the
[ __ ] arrogance of every [ __ ] here on
Twitter it's like no I've never heard of
that expression what does it mean of
course I've heard of that [ __ ]
expression
you jerk off
that means when you see the iceberg
above the [ __ ] water that's just the
tip of it it's way bigger beneath it
see so you [ __ ] go wide around the
goddamn thing
I think the guy driving the boat got
blown and uh he drove right into the
[ __ ] thing I just think they didn't
see it and they drove right into the
[ __ ] thing and I'm sure that what cut
it was under the water line and they off
they could have sideswiped this thing
or maybe they couldn't have but I don't
know when neither does the other douche
all I did was retweet a picture and then
he's given me [ __ ]
have you ever heard the expression the
tip of the iceberg no I haven't
you ever hear that joke why the chicken
cross the road oh it's a great one I
wrote it last week
tip of the iceberg [ __ ] goddamn
Expressions almost as old as this piece
of [ __ ] house oh this [ __ ] house
oh there we go all right
Happy Thanksgiving one-man Thrill Ride
and then I had the wrong one
I'm the [ __ ] worst where is it
retweet you know what I'm going to
retweet this guy's uh
oh there it is
for information at One Man Thrill Ride
is an imposter and a fraud he's getting
reported okay so the one that you want
if you want to follow Jimmy Preston you
got to follow at Thrill Ride Capital CW
all right that's the real one there you
go
and I'm calling it right now
I'm calling it right now he's going to
make it to uh the WWE whatever the [ __ ]
they used to call the WWF when I was a
kid and then I think like Walmart or
somebody sued him I don't [ __ ] know I
don't know
well what do you want from me so uh
sorry I just had to put that up there
sorry about that um
so how you guys doing this week did you
did you survive Black Friday did you
survive Black Friday
stupid ass [ __ ] we're out of shape
people trample each other into some of
the shittiest [ __ ] stores on the
planet why can't you just admit that
you're broke
you know and just be like kids I'm sorry
we don't have any money there's no Santa
Claus why can't you just do that you're
going to run down there and try to get a
weed whacker for [ __ ] six bucks or
whatever the hell you're trying to do
just deal
you can't afford it if you got to get
trampled just so you can maybe buy it
you can't afford it and you just gotta
would you got to deal with that you got
to deal with the fact that you would
dealt
uh a [ __ ] broke ass hand and now you
got to play it and that's not the way
you play it
you don't get out of poverty by going
down to a department store and getting
trampled the day after Thanksgiving
what you do is you gotta [ __ ] get out
you gotta figure out you gotta [ __ ]
tighten the belt
you gotta tighten the [ __ ] belt
[ __ ] kids
what about my kids what a bottle
don't get him anything
don't get him anything for Christmas and
let him cry
you know what and then what happens
someday they put out a [ __ ] they do
something with their lives
that'll kill them they go to school and
they got nothing and all the kids are
teasing them
and all those [ __ ] jerk offs that get
everything for [ __ ] Christmas they
don't have any Drive what do they do
they sit around doing [ __ ] ecstasy
wait for their parents to die so they
can get the money that that that's what
you want for your kid
all right
you give your kid a little bit of Drive
all right and then you as a parent you
make sure you don't get trampled
I mean that's Paige why do we have a kid
and I [ __ ] know that I know goddamn
well if I was to go broke okay and I had
a goddamn Kid the last thing I would do
the day after Thanksgiving is go down
there and get [ __ ] trampled
okay why would I do that I need to be in
physical shape so I can go back the next
Friday and shoplift
okay when there's the right amount of
people in the store that's how you
[ __ ] get your Christmas
okay you steal from these [ __ ] you
don't get yourself [ __ ] trampled
that's a suckers game
all right
so pass this along if you have any
friends or family out there that got
trampled the day after Thanksgiving can
you imagine that you're just full of
[ __ ] turkey and stuffing sweet potato
pie or whatever the [ __ ] you had whipped
cream and eggnog with a little bit of
bourbon
you know what's wrong with you
Jesus [ __ ] Christ either just admit
that you're broke or shoplift
but there is no reason to get trampled
okay
in 2014 there's just no [ __ ] I'm
trying to think of a reason to get if
there's a fire yes
there's a fire absolutely
um anyways ah [ __ ] say my God damn
name it's probably karma for making fun
of poor people and making fun of poor
people I'm trying to give them incentive
stop making [ __ ] stupid moves in life
I don't have any money for Christmas
gifts what's my next move I think I'll
go down and get trampled at Walmart
all right let's do a little bit of a uh
a little bit of um advertising here and
then I'm gonna spoil a movie for you to
start December off right and then I'm
going to bring in a special guest who's
got a big show coming up uh let's get
with the advertising here on the Monday
Morning podcast all right
I'm gonna uh spoil a movie spoiler alert
I'm going to ruin this [ __ ] movie
all right what should I do should I give
you guys one week to go see the movie
you want me to ruin it
well unfortunately I can't hear what
you're saying right now so
the movie is Gone Girl
right now if there's any women listening
to this podcast they're going oh my God
oh my God oh my God shut it off shut it
off
shut it off
um if there's any guy they're like oh
didn't Ben Affleck already make that
[ __ ] movie
um
this is all I'm going to say about that
movie all right it's two and a half
hours long the first two hours and 15
minutes are great
total enjoyment
all right
and then two hours and 15 minutes in
every character just Taps out and
doesn't give a [ __ ]
and then Tyler Perry just goes man you
[ __ ] are crazy and then just
walks away and that's kind of the end of
the movie
I've never been to a movie that was two
and a half hours long 200 two hours and
15 minutes I'm in there
and I want to see what happens two hours
and 16 minutes in if the people I was
with said hey let's all get up and walk
on I'd be like fine and I would never
think about the movie again
and this has nothing to do with the
acting has nothing to do with the
directing it's just the story what
happened did you paint yourselves into a
[ __ ] corner
I don't get it everybody just said yeah
just you know
the classic tireless cop I'm gonna stay
on this till I get Justice all the other
cops seen in a different way and they're
like I see it this way
then all of a sudden this new
information and then they're just like
yeah well you're probably right but you
know there's nothing I can do
this [ __ ] cop character she had a cop
uniform on her hair up the whole [ __ ]
goddamn movie and she's taking
everything seriously and then in the end
when someone actually is killed she lets
her [ __ ] hair down takes off her
uniforms just like yeah but I can never
prove it
all right go [ __ ] yourselves have a
Happy Thanksgiving
I don't know I don't know what to tell
you I'm sorry I ruined that movie
um
I'm gonna have to [ __ ] that's gonna
have to be in the advertising of it
because I hate ruining [ __ ] for people
but it was just it just annoyed the [ __ ]
out of me but anyways
let me hit pause here and go get my
guest hang on
all right with the magic of the pause
button we are back with my very special
guest
uh Rose Bowl tailgate Legend and four
star
stealth undercover Chef unless you're a
lovely lady and you bend over his house
uh Jason lied everyone how are you sir
I like being in your like waiting room
out here while you're doing the first
step because you're just yelling what
were you yelling about because I'm out
there in the waiting room watching the
end of the Packers uh uh New England
game which you know I knew once we
missed the field goals like it's over
and I gotta get this [ __ ] thing done
because I have no free time in my life
anymore but uh I think that that game
was yelling about
um I don't know it felt it was funny to
me because for a while after I just got
set in the trance there it felt like I
was sitting outside waiting to get
yelled at like you know when somebody's
getting yelling through yeah like for my
case like growing up with like the coach
you know on the other side of the office
wall and you're just like oh God I'm in
there next oh no no you know the usual
like just screaming about uh people
getting trampled on Black Friday just
saying you should just admit that you
broke not get your kids any gifts and
that'll give them Drive yeah remember
Biggie Smalls
wondering why Christmas missed us
birthdays was the worst days now we
drink champagne when we're third state
right yeah his mother didn't go down
there and get trampled look what
happened to him yeah well
well that's some other [ __ ]
oh the karma came back to him tenfold
what Karma no I'm just saying she didn't
get trampled I didn't mean it like in
carpet yeah yeah he didn't do anything
wrong like she didn't get trampled so I
was guilty of being the best rapper all
of that era and it's not even close I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] piss
off any African Americans that I have on
this or uh want to be white kids
uh a white white guy wannabes I should
say wannabe white kids uh I don't think
Tupac is even in the [ __ ] same class
is Biggie Biggie's raps were like movies
yeah painted pictures and he and he had
all these different ways all this
different flow I believe the kids say
right everything was different he he had
he had that talk was good too though but
I get what you're saying on the
difference of it all and that Tupac all
his [ __ ] sounds the same to me his the
way he Rhymes is the same
and I think I'm gonna die yeah but I I
you know I always thought he was gonna
die I'm not saying he's bad but to sit
there and act like that dude was even
remotely as good as I think he's like
you're Patrice like he's your yeah yeah
like Biggie's like you're Patrice O'Neal
in that in the in the and I'm not gonna
sail Tupac is because I don't need I
don't need to get shot at a [ __ ]
Comedy Club it's hilarious it's
hilarious no I just started with my kids
after we get off there you know I
haven't even thought about it I'm gonna
give you time though but his his his uh
his sense of humor his ability to tell
his story
I mean I haven't let's do [ __ ] in so
[ __ ] long but uh what was that I got
a story to tell that one where he's
telling the story amazing and then he's
in the story and then the dude comes
home or that one took me forever I was
listening to it and he's rapping and
then they put his voice over the phone
uh
uh uh having the guy warn it the warning
remember that one yeah who the [ __ ] is
this yeah five four to six in the
morning that one whatever that one is
it's the funnest impression yeah I don't
think you know he does a weekend with
Larry Spears recently and he does that a
lot through he got him back and do oh
he does it really good he does a really
good he's like what are you talking
about banquet and he's just like goes
and then he'll just keep bringing it
back and I don't know who you just
sounded like but I'm thinking Warner
Brothers yeah I know um no all right
Aries Spears is like uh his his final
like closing bit like when he just and
he just keeps adding to it he just keeps
whoever is contemporary at the time and
they are dead on yep
but we are here to promote uh Jason
lawhead everybody uh from Lorraine
Lorraine Ohio Lorraine Ohio is making
his triumphant return
to stage and Screen he's got a big
theater date back there over the
holidays we got to push this date number
27th I can't wait it's cool it's a big
uh big haul I'm doing like what's the
name of the theater the the Palace
Theater in Lorain Ohio it's uh an old
almost took a wrecking ball years ago
and like a lot of locals saved it you
know as far as like building a
foundation and everything and uh I've
seen a lot of awesome you know I've seen
Willie Nelson there Bob Dylan there
Stephen right there and uh I mean The
Bigs have come through there and it's uh
it's exciting it's a big
I need people to spread the word man
because it's a big place yeah now if I
got like 700 to 800 I'd be really happy
but obviously you want to sell out
that's right yeah Jay that's what we're
trying to do yeah rather you don't you
don't promote a date going you know if
it half cells well you should have never
been to where I'm from you know it's
it's very it's very uh you know I love
it but it's very ghost Towny at this
point
um it's Jake could you be doing anything
more to not sell this date no I would
have fallen a ghost town no I'm saying
tumbleweeds no no the downtown's great
I'm saying this the theater's awesome
it's just can't tell you something Jake
I love the [ __ ] Midwest and I love
town just like the town you're talking
about I [ __ ] love those towns I love
the old downtown that's [ __ ] no one
goes there anymore because they built a
[ __ ] Target or a Walmart I still love
going down to those [ __ ] places the
people look great they're gonna show up
oh they are they're gonna show up so
it's December 27th yeah that's a great
what's the name of the venue uh it's the
Palace Theater in Lorraine man I'm gonna
be doing my uh uh you know uh album
release that night my first CD uh that's
[ __ ] awesome called you never heard
of me
um is coming out that night and I'll
that'll be the hard copy uh you know
released that night and uh you know well
then you know when's the first of your
hits we'll be doing some digital
downloads and stuff off the website yeah
but it's a good piece I'm happy about
with some added tracks from my hometown
and Chicago's which will be cool so
there's just some all right so if you're
listening to this if you're anywhere
near
and you can make it try to get out there
and uh even if you can't if you just do
a favor for one of my best friends in
the business on and off stage uh just
we're gonna have a tweet uh about the
show for Ticket links just if you get a
chance if you could retweet it just to
help get the word out uh you know you
definitely deserve it man it'd be
awesome to have a big uh big win on the
holidays dude
around Christmas they've wanted me to
come back a little bit so it was
flattering because they kind of called
me which was the cool part you know like
I hadn't uh that I didn't really
consider that as one of the venues I was
looking at to try to go home and do a
show but uh they really sold me on the
fact that they were interested and they
promoted and uh yeah man it's it's cool
so we'll probably probably do a little
local media around there uh hopefully
close to it and uh
yeah man I mean uh you do those big
theaters all the time I've done some of
them with you this one's a really
beautiful old Grand Theater and uh but I
know the feeling whenever you go to do
it with me and bring me out and uh he's
gonna he's gonna come out and uh you
know rile up the crowd a little bit so I
still have that feeling whenever I go to
do a theater you always peeking out like
did anybody show up you always feel I I
even feel that like a comedy club after
I've seen you after years before like
let's just hope I sell something you're
like ah Bill you're gonna but yeah I've
seen you kind of you know it's straight
now I'm straight I'm you listen this is
the first time I've ever had to deal
with that kind of stress like it's all
great the Banners are great everybody's
cooperating their people are buying
we've we know that people have started
going online and now we got a little
buzz going and this is the rush we got a
little thing but yeah it's uh you know
when you when you know how many seats
are out there you're like wow man this
is this is pretty wild but it's cool man
it's gonna be fun man well we'll get uh
we'll get the all things Comedy Network
uh which you're a part of I'm coming on
board I just uh talked to those guys
last week we'll try to get a nice push
maybe yeah nice little launch interview
launch I get a big promo this weekend I
forgot I'm such a [ __ ] loser I
haven't seen any I haven't seen anything
from you on a tweet we don't know what
uh it looks like uh I know that you you
ripped on me uh a couple of weeks ago
for bombing your intro that was a
hilarious Story by the way but I mean we
haven't even seen any branding on you
especially where like I got to open for
that thing and I haven't even seen like
a a poster or a tweet or it's coming
this week my special actually comes out
uh December 5th yeah December 5th yeah
the fifth going on Conan this week to
promote it oh nice uh I already went out
and bought my shirt
I always go out and got to buy a shirt
yeah you know maybe some shoes how many
times is this on the couch for Conan
with you now that's a lot I don't like
four or five he's awesome man that guy's
like you know if it's going well he
laughs if you you know if you need some
help he's right there to bail you out
Andy's always there to bail you out and
uh
you know he likes when you go crazy you
know make it a little uncomfortable
whatever it's just it's just he's a good
guy man he's a real good guy he had a
great tweet every tweeted on
Thanksgiving where he said uh uh just
got done eating one of these grass-fed
Colorado turkeys can't figure out why I
can I have the munchies all day he did
like a you know yeah the way he ordered
it was great I don't know I think I
butchered it but well hey um I didn't
get to see the final two minutes of the
game I've got to be honest with you
would we lose by four yeah they just ran
out you know they got the first down and
ran out the clock they've had him at
third and four but obviously Rogers made
a good good play Oh do they but did you
secondary was [ __ ] getting toasted
man every time I was [ __ ] well that
Jordy Nelson slant across the middle
that 80s when he hit the pylon oh Jesus
yeah what's [ __ ] two seconds left in
the first half that's what that was the
backbreaker because you you worry
because you guys were actually playing
it like you could get the ball back you
had two timeouts left if you could get a
backbreaker was the sack yeah well that
was moved us back yeah but I think the
scoring right foreign
you [ __ ] up in the second quarter the
fourth quarter you blow it yeah that's
that's that's how I look at this [ __ ]
but uh did you see Oakland did you see
some of the highlights I I haven't seen
anything wait till you see the Oakland
Raider highlights watch it all they got
be 52 to nothing by the by the ring by
the same old Rams
quarterback Bradford's been out the
whole season
Steve deberg did they bring did they
bring back Testaverde yeah Vince Paragon
I don't even know who played
quarterbacks all I saw was highlights of
these guys tripping like running after
Trey Austin tripping these guys are
tripping and falling down it looked like
trying to get kids to listen their
defense when they would make I mean
somebody's highlights and Tony sparano
you wait till you see the the the
interview he looks like he doesn't take
his sunglasses off anymore he looks like
uh Rocky looking over Mickey's corpse he
looks so beat up he did not even want to
talk he had his head down with
sunglasses on and he was just like yeah
I mean oh yeah that poor guy because
it's his second time he's me and verses
favorite guys just his whole [ __ ]
name he looks like he's Witness
Protection Program and when he used to
coach the Dolphins Tony and almost Tony
Soprano whenever I say Tony Soprano can
never remember how to say his name is
Tony
sparano yes Tony sparano the peas in the
beginning oh okay yeah it's not surprise
they take a pee from the back of soprano
and put it in the beginning spirano oh
yeah yeah oh the other thing I was
yelling about by the way is I uh
well I may not do add here and jump all
around uh Ray Rice is coming back there
you go some people I was joking about
that on stage people are pissed off like
I guess your NFL doesn't care so we're
talking they find the guy millions of
dollars and the thing was is billions
for suspension I've always said they've
given him the first suspension already
he accepted it and then he got suspended
again they got suspended again and he
played yeah he said and the woman he hit
married him exactly exactly and then she
stuck up for him because there's bags of
money going out the window just came up
again yesterday and said she wasn't a
victim Jesus said she reiterated in
another article when he got reinstated
that she she reiterated it again I mean
you know I say if the smartest I
wouldn't go as far as she's not a victim
I would just say she said she would yeah
but she loves that dude or he's got her
psychologically like
dude you punch a woman's face and drag
her down the hall by her hair yeah she's
a victim if he did that to me granny you
had no hair to grab you [ __ ] grabbed
me under my freckled chin I yeah I am a
victim of a [ __ ] knockout
she probably feels like she's more of a
victim for the fact that she doesn't get
to live the lifestyle she gets to live
when she when he's playing I gotta be
honest with you man that's it to take a
punch like that and then just say like
I'm not a victim that just seems like uh
that we're coming in on the middle of
the movie and or she's just like I don't
know where she [ __ ] grew up that
that's just a [ __ ] normal week like
what is everybody flipping out about but
Back to Football if I was the Saints he
could have left me in the elevator he
brought me in he tucked me in yeah I
woke up the next day a couple of Advil
it's like it never happened
that's [ __ ] hilarious to just sit
because you know women's groups will
just like flipping out it's just so much
fun to watch them women's groups
actually have like a like someone on
there allegedly their side actually
arguing with them because there's no way
guys can do it I'm making all kinds of
noise this weekend through this chair
and there's no way guys can [ __ ] do
it it's just it's got really gotten to
the point that like like there's certain
groups if they complain people are so
afraid
of saying the wrong thing and losing
money in advertisers or their job or any
of that that they will just sit there
and they will listen to anything from a
hundred percent logic and genius to
Absolute lunacy it doesn't make a
difference it's just the topic what are
we talking about you know whatever
cancer or battered women or [ __ ]
whatever you're talking about people
just go okay that makes sense right I'll
wear the pink thing
tell me where to walk where I'll have a
pink mustache in December Matt Lauer
would do it right did you see Dave
Letterman trash Matt Lauer that was one
of the [ __ ] most brutal things
because you know he got into it with
that lady on his show and then she
[ __ ] pulled this genius [ __ ] move
where she started tearing up after they
fired her right and then he reached out
to touch her and she pulled away and
just totally made him look like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] so for the last like
[ __ ] 14 months he's trying to show
how playful and silly and how he doesn't
take himself seriously or whatever and I
forget what the [ __ ] he was doing there
was some sort of stunt he was doing
where he was running around shirtless
doing something just looking like
everything but just wearing a dress and
Letterman showed a clip and goes look at
that would you look at that that is a
grown man with children ladies and
gentlemen and he just goes who is his
agent and he goes play that again wow
and it was and it was tough love but the
guy needed to hear it and he's he's not
doing it as ridiculous but he somebody
needed to be like dude for [ __ ] sakes
how long are you going to apologize with
your [ __ ] self-esteem here have a
little bit of backbone
and you okay see you didn't get along
with one [ __ ] person the entire time
so now you got to go out there and you
know dress like a pinata and have a
bunch of kids whack you with a stick
Jesus man
that's uh you know well I'm listening to
you just rant but I'm like I'm sitting
here going you know I don't understand
how the network even stays with a guy
that's that's toting that after the
whole fact I mean well then that way
they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ] what you're doing
let's just say that certain somebody
that had all those accusations right
well right but let's just say that guy
you think you do you think if he was
really doing that to all of those women
do you honestly think that only those
women knew about it right you don't
think there was producers and directors
and other actors and all kinds of
[ __ ] people that knew something was
going on dude once you start making
people money yeah that's true you know
if that I mean I should I shouldn't be
using that as an example because that is
all alleged and I believe yeah innocent
until guilty or 13 000 accusations
somebody said I saw a funny tweet I
don't know who said it but it was like
uh The Bill Cosby thing is a it's a
classic case of he said she said dot dot
dot she said that that she said like 13
she said oh man that's a that's
hilarious that's a rough one you know
that escalated quickly yes it did that
oh that's a that's another one they show
the Ron Burgundy thing after the news
broke with uh Bill McCarthy and then all
the like like and then this story came
out they showed like quick clips and
news stories like people going and now
another woman
wow that escalated quickly yeah there's
a thing too like I I try not because you
know
I'm a [ __ ] idiot and I've made a
bunch of mistakes and all that [ __ ] I
try not to [ __ ] judge people until
they've actually just been like but
sometimes you're just like what the [ __ ]
like I knew this guy one time right I
didn't know this guy it was just someone
who knew a guy who knew a guy knew a guy
within my circle and that's one of those
deals you know you get that phone call
and someone goes hey do you remember so
and so and you're like oh [ __ ] what is
he dead and they're like nah and there
was this [ __ ] story where this guy
had got arrested for uh like child
trafficking sex [ __ ] blah blah blah
and I was like oh my God what is he in
[ __ ] Thailand what is this guy doing
turned out he got a hooker who was
underage oh and say oh he had a bad
weekend yeah the guy in a bad [ __ ]
week I mean
you pull over and you get a hooker am I
wrong here you get it the first thing
you do you're trying to get her in the
car right exactly she's doing something
illegal what is she going to show you
her real ID
the guy was married had kids he had a
bad weekend
[ __ ] yeah but he was trafficking that
sucks geez no but the way they put it in
like the local like police blurb made it
seem like this guy was wasn't charged
with that was he like I don't I mean I
mean this is years ago I just had one
[ __ ] phone call about it and I was
just like what the [ __ ] and then the guy
told me the story
because I'm literally going like that
dude was into little kids and it's just
like no you got a prostitute
and she was under it I was like ah all
right I mean that's I mean I don't know
how far underage but I'm assuming like
but I mean you could literally you gotta
hope it's give or take a couple of years
and if she's walking the streets dude
they age and dog years 17 year old's
gonna look 35. it's true I saw one
nobody is thinking how old are you when
you get a hooker you're not thinking
that you're thinking are you a cop
that's what you're thinking yeah did you
see that ever see that HBO uh special on
hookers like when they walk the streets
of like uh these cities at night [ __ ]
one deep voice guy does the you know I
remember that yeah remember those HBO
things one o'clock in the morning and
but there was like they would tell these
group like show these girls that would
come forward like 31 32 33 years old
looked Haggard like 50. they looked 50.
just beat down with the drugs and
they're just concrete and Jizzle do that
to you I'll do it to you it's a rough
life out there rough life and you're
walking in those pumps you know your
[ __ ] back is all messed up you know
it's not bugging me I didn't see the
people keep texting me the new no more
commercial I haven't seen it yet so
maybe I'll See You by next week uh but
those [ __ ] Dodge Ram commercials
what what is this slogan with it like
Unity dignity
realm what is what do they say there's
like these these [ __ ] ridiculous
words I don't know the actuals like them
but they're always like they went to the
moon and back it's just some guy driving
down the street with a ladder and I got
like some [ __ ] uh [ __ ] and one bucket
of stucco or some [ __ ] in the back
they're acting like they're going to war
and they always slowed down the truck
like taking bumps I I hate that when
they like slow the truck down taking
these bumps like it's like only in this
truck could you be this coming over like
yeah you're gonna load this up and drive
over a bunch of Tree Trunks yeah it's
laying in the road just in case there's
a hurricane you got a bunch of telephone
poles to ride over Dude those things
ride we rent we rent uh we rent a big we
rent a four-door pickup every year when
we go to the Rose Bowl that's what I was
thinking about it because uh guts that's
it that's Glory rail God's glory right
because when you said the first time I'm
like I don't remember hearing all right
what's the guts to take on that payment
and that gas guzzling tax what's the
glory find it somewhere to park that
thing parallel park that thing yeah like
they've carried a flag look at that I
got that thing in you know what I mean
they didn't let the flag touch the
ground yeah they're not they're coming
over to some old [ __ ] like me to
[ __ ] charge me up the ass yep we got
the Rose Bowl menu coming this year oh
yeah and those of you who are new to my
podcast every year uh me and a number of
other fellas we all go to the Rose Bowl
game and this year dude it's a playoff
game oh this one's gonna be a big
this one counts for all of my mouth no
it doesn't it's a semi-final playoff
game dude I gotta tell you it was almost
sold out yeah all right like I got I got
us four tickets I had to go two and two
so that was a couple rows behind us God
God help same area God help the people
between us as we shout out so we can
kind of go give absolutely look over the
shoulder yeah yeah it's always sad when
we have to go to the game anyway I hope
the implications of this one cheers them
up a little bit because he hates leaving
the tailgate well we all do but we all
do yeah especially hey
is the worst
yeah
[Music]
so uh no dude oh man we're gonna do the
ribs this year I like your idea we're
going with your idea we're gonna do the
ribs this year when I shotgun that beer
last year that's kind of the last part
of the tailgate remember and I just woke
up in the lawn chair last year I went so
hard for the people who I I I'm the
first guy who ever passed out at the
tailgate hardest I've ever seen you ever
go and we've we've we've you know we've
had some nights where we've knocked them
back and that was the hardest do you
know what I've ever seen and do you know
I had never shotgun a bear in my life
you could just never but why it went
right down what are you talking I
crushed it oh what I'm saying is you
know a little bit later you were sitting
down that thing went that thing was like
the lubricator for you and then that
that's what that thought oh no dude no
no that that was dude you know how many
whiskeys I was invited that's what I
mean whiskey that's what I mean is like
that thing lubricated you to just be
able to go well boom that's what that's
what I mean like you had never it was
like that they're like taking a drug for
the first when you start drinking
whiskey at 8 30 in the morning at 11 30
to drink a beer it's like it's like yeah
it's like drinking like orange juice yep
I can't even just we went right down
I just I never shotgun a beer I just
never that's there was always girls
around I always thought I was going to
drip down my [ __ ] shirt and I was
like they're already not hooking up with
me I don't need to add spilling alcohol
all over myself Jefferson College
doesn't sound like the type of college
where they're shotgun and beer lawn oh
sure they are of course they were I was
a commuter yeah dude I lived in a bubble
for the first 25 years of my life
um so anyways um
getting back to it so uh this year dude
uh so we got
um dude Alabama might be playing in the
[ __ ] Rose Bowl be right now uh
Alabama
right now would be Alabama well
Mississippi State lost I'm saying tcus
probably four right now I don't think so
until you say yeah come on
it's no
it's no 10 Big Ten not necessarily no
unless they're both in the unless
they're both in the top four so we could
see SEC obviously Alabama what am I
thinking here's what it's going to be
you know how they were rotating the
Bulls for the championship in the last
couple years before they went to the
final four playoff system yeah what
they're going to do is they're going to
rotate the semifinals the the the
championship game is now gonna is not a
BCS game anymore so it's not at one of
those five sites anymore this year's BC
this year's title game they're calling
it the title game is that Dallas Cowboys
Stadium next year it's at Glendale in
Phoenix where they play where the
Cardinals play the year after that
they've already got the first three
sites already met the third year is
Tampa because it's going to be like a
Super Bowl of right they're gonna have
destination cities so what they're going
to do is they don't have to pay the kids
they're gonna make a fortune they're
gonna they're gonna rotate the five so
next year the Rose Bowl won't be one of
the semifinal games either the Orange
Bowl or the
Cotton Bowl or the um
so there's five I think out of the five
cities every every couple years though
there'll be a semi-final and I would go
to the Cowboys one basically every two
years the Rose Bowl is going to be a
semi-final game that's sick I would go
to the cowboys that championship game if
they just took that [ __ ] TV down yeah
the TV is the [ __ ] worse yeah I've
never been in here yet well uh I was
working a comedy club out there and the
the owner out there had a hookup and we
sat down on the field level and dude you
couldn't not look at it I was pulling
the visor down on my hat so I wouldn't
look my neck was stiff you just dude
it's clearer than what's going on it's
clearer than real life is it and it's
like watching the spaceship land
everybody the only way I would go to
that game I would never sit on the lower
level again if I ever went to Cowboys
team I would sit you know mid to up and
I would just you just sitting there like
watching TV outside but inside
where it's happening but you're sort of
a million miles away because you're
watching this [ __ ] screen and
um
I don't know man like I there's
something about that Stadium when
there's college football in it I love it
man when I saw like LSU in or and they
you know they have the [ __ ] uh the
end zones that painted their colors it's
a really cool
Stadium it sucks that eventually the
Cotton Bowl is going to be in there
um that's why I went to um well actually
caught bullies but uh the the Red River
game is eventually going to be in there
won't even be played at the Cotton Bowl
that's why I went to it a couple years
back and it's just like the Rose Bowl
where it's about half the size of like
Gillette Stadium right but holds like a
hundred and ten thousand people or
something like that and you're sitting
there going there's no way there's a
hundred thousand people it's like yeah
there is all there is is seats nothing
and everybody's just jammed together on
like [ __ ] aluminum seats and stuff so
um that Rose Bowl Stadium is great
that's what that's just I love going
into that stadium and watching football
every year that's just that's one of the
best places you'll ever see anything in
your life sports related why I think
I've been in some cool Parks now you've
been in a lot more than I have but man
every time I step into that Rose Bowl
Stadium to watch that game and see those
teams painted on the field I I don't
know if there's a January 1st sunshine I
don't know if there's anything I don't
know if there's a pound for pound a
sporting event that is a consistent
thing as great as the Masters is I I
don't know a Rose Ball
is great just to start the year off to
dude there's no bet as far as like it
defines like if you're if you're like
the same kind of [ __ ] we are right
because we are morons right that's the
perfect perfect I'm kind of like this
girl I was talking she's like well they
don't some people just don't understand
and I get dude you know what I did
Thanksgiving day I taped all the games I
watched the last one I didn't watch the
first two games you don't actually did
um I was like in a Mellow Mood and Nia
didn't want to watch football she wanted
to watch the Westminster dog show well I
know what happened I took my dog on a
hike right and then I came back he went
on like this [ __ ] two-hour hike right
and come back and then uh I come in and
she already has the Macy Day Parade on
I'm like a joke here we go right
um
and some band was playing that song uh
cause I'm happy
yeah
yep they were killing it too yeah they
were killing it right and you know I
like the drum line in that type of [ __ ]
song but then I need more things that
put me in a good mood anyway so I'm not
gonna be I'm not gonna worry about
admitting that I like that song that's
all right you know sorry well even if
people are laughing right now you can't
hear it that's the greatest thing about
this you're in the bubble so she she
wanted to watch it and I said ah you
know what [ __ ] it it's Thanksgiving I'm
not gonna argue let's do it all right
let's [ __ ] watch it and I totally got
into it and I dude I called it verzie I
[ __ ] I can't say I knew the dog was
gonna win but the one that I picked that
I wanted to win there was this [ __ ]
Bloodhound was it a blood oh I love
Bloodhounds right
and I made it to the final round it was
that it was a sick ass [ __ ] Japanese
dog uh because with an a I don't know
what it is but it's [ __ ] jacked
awesome looking dog uh looks I think
that they bred him to fight Bears there
was so many so much [ __ ] information
I can't even remember
um
and uh the [ __ ] Bloodhound one you
know what he [ __ ] he he got to the
judge
all the dogs were sitting there all
priming proper and that thing sat down
as the thing came over it sat on its ass
and started scratching its ear or
something like there its side and then
when the the judge kind of lifted its
you know you know behind quarters come
on let's stand up it just sort of looked
at him and gave him a big [ __ ] uh
kiss on the face you know but one bit
you know the giant [ __ ] Bloodhound
took into a paintbrush to the face no
kidding and the judge looked away and
then just couldn't even
he had this [ __ ] ear to ear grin and
even the people announcing were laughing
going uh I think that dog knows what
it's doing but blah blah blah and the
[ __ ] thing came in first place
because I'm saying NEOS because there's
no way they're giving it to a bloodhound
there's no way those are cool dogs yeah
I know but when you just think like you
know Best in Show it's usually one of
those foofy looking dogs didn't what
wasn't uh what's his name uh had one in
the finals invest in show in the movie
it's a stupid version um Christopher
guess remember he had the big ones I
never saw that movie oh that's a funny
movie Fred Willard kills it in that
movie but anyway he had in the finals he
had a blood Jane Lynch's in that movie I
gotta see it Christopher gastautos guys
Harry Shear all those guys you want to
ruin it for me the way I ruined a movie
for everybody on uh
on the podcast this week what are you
doing the garden girl you ruined it I
basically said that for [ __ ] uh two
hours and 15 minutes
it's a great movie the final 15 minutes
I didn't like that's what I said I
probably shouldn't have said that I
should have just said there that I
wasn't going to give out any more
information
um go and see it and you'll know yeah
you'll know exactly what I'm saying hey
you want to do some questions here yeah
man let's do some questions I I like
doing the questions all right whistling
in the bathroom uh what the [ __ ] up what
the [ __ ] is up with dudes whistling in
the men's room they walk in Whistling
away take their piss wash their hands
dry off and leave and the entire time
they're [ __ ] whistling why it's weird
knock that [ __ ] off do you know uh do
you know why they do this
um I would say that they're already a
douchebag who walks around whistling and
when you go in there the acoustics
these sound it's like singing in the
shower to them and
um by the people who whistle in general
are really like uh they're in their own
[ __ ] world
because you can't you're not just
picking up on how [ __ ] annoying it is
right especially when you're just in a
group of people that you're Stranger in
you know like that situation but some
people I think might be just happy that
they're going to be touching themselves
oh so that's what he's happy I don't
know man maybe gonna go in there and see
some dicks yeah I don't know that's a
different angle hey all right I'm like
it's kind of like stepping like a hey
all right I'm happy about this decision
I made I mean taking my dick out yeah
man you're gonna be touching my dick and
this is gonna be great
you know what I mean like I don't know
that could be uh that could be what's
going on but I used to work in a
warehouse and there was a guy that could
whistle really well but he's doing it
and he'd wait for like guitar solos that
would come on the radio and he would
only whistle like three or four notes
but he did it every [ __ ] day in the
exact same register like he'd wait to
the guitar solo guy up to a certain
point you would always whistle a couple
of [ __ ] notes
and um
I think he did it for about six months
before I finally just looked at him I go
why do you always do that
and he was like do what and I was like
whistle
with the [ __ ] guitar solo
it's like you know didn't even know he
was doing it so no and he had this I
know and you know I felt bad after I
said it because he was absolutely
stunned like he had no idea like dude he
was looking at me like dude like I
thought we were friends I had to break
it's classic me back then I could have
it a while back from years ago that I
didn't know I was doing that was
annoying people
um and that was uh like this like this
real shriek through my teeth
like well Jesus don't ever do that again
no I'm not I broke myself of it but I
wouldn't know I was doing it and that
guy would do it like like either not
awkward like or some nervous situations
or something or like thoughtful
situations and I wouldn't know that I
was doing it like I would fall into it
like yeah you ever fall into like a
stair where you just can't see like you
just fall out and you're like yeah but I
don't know what I would think people
would you know finally somebody close
enough your friends are close enough
that are just like dude and you're like
uh and then you hear it enough times to
be like all right and then I consciously
broke it I don't do it anymore which is
great I mean there you go it's been a
while everybody should do that you want
to be able to walk up to that guy in the
men's room yeah and be like you're like
dude are you even aware that you walked
in here whistling no one wants to hear
it yeah there's always that guy too that
like the old old guys fart when they
piss it's [ __ ] hilarious they just
[ __ ] go and they just
weren't they just have like those ones
and they don't even smell it's like it's
so loud it eats it eats up the smell
you never notice that noise if it just
you know it eats the [ __ ] yeah
oh my God all the time especially like
at airports you know what I mean like
when you're ducking in like like the
terminal and you know you got there
early okay I can go in and have a nice
little just you know you know take you
know take my time in the restroom and
you're just in there you're trying to
relax because you know you can take your
thing and it's like
there's like two sometimes there's like
two guys doing and they just don't those
guys just don't even give a [ __ ] how
dude I've been in there and it's just
like almost every stall is packed you've
already taken a piss and you're up there
trying to wash your hands not touch
anything and they just be sunk up
you ever seen a guy right and people and
what's funny is nobody says anything
because you expect to hear it you expect
to smell it when you're in there it's
like if that guy did that on the plane
you would either die laughing or [ __ ]
punch him in the face but in the
bathroom it's just completely acceptable
to just
it's just nobody gives a [ __ ]
and what's so funny is you're in there
and there's literally a complete
stranger like six feet away
just [ __ ]
and what you're smelling is the air
that's been up his ass and you just
don't even you don't even give a [ __ ]
you just say yeah I'm in a men's room
that's just what it is and then you go
out you go out to [ __ ] you don't have
a Chick-fil-A and you get a sandwich and
you actually act like it never happened
oh my god dude I'm dying right now yeah
it's [ __ ] unreal oh my God that's
hilarious
totally acceptable
um all right you ready for another one
oh Jesus you're here we can talk about
this oh my God that Asian guy then he
started cleaning us
he started doing his feet
just doing that thing off the heel and
he was getting a dead skin off his face
he was just letting him swing around he
just had like he was almost like opening
his thighs it was it was very yes I just
think it was like a uh
I think it's just a different level of
comfortableness like you know I saw the
different this of our comfortableness is
the last people who owned this house was
a gay couple so they had that that
magazine that comes every once in a
while dude that was fun and I'm going
like you know all these like cowboys
with like assless chaps and they got
these looks they got these looks on
their face
and they got these looks on their faces
like this that same attitude like a
Victoria's Secret model has like you
know you could never have this [ __ ] so
I'm sitting there going like so I'm
sitting there trying to show it to Jay
and he literally he's already standing
up he literally turns his back and is
walking away going like
I don't want to see that I'm like come
on look at the guys mustaches I don't
wanna I don't want to see this come on
dude you were so repulsed like I sat
there going like wait a minute there's
something wrong with me am I'm either
[ __ ] uh Forward Thinking here or I'm
falling on the other side of the fence
God it was like a you know it was like a
oh dude it's hilarious it was like a
Magic Mike collector's item no it's like
one of those uh one of those right but
I'm just saying that's you know the
pictures he's the way these guys were
looking at you oh Magic Mike yeah
they're about to strip you know what I
mean oh yeah no they had the exact same
attitude uh as uh that was hilarious
like you're not good enough for this
what did you say you'll never get this
I'll never forget this yeah what do you
do for a living buddy they did look it
looked like that yeah um all right
transitioning to becoming a professional
um I recently fulfilled a lifelong dream
of becoming a professional comic book
honest congratulations dude now there's
a fun job because that provided you
don't work for Disney because they'll
probably take all the creativity out of
it why did I just say that skeptical as
I was that I would never find I'm just
getting in their good graces saying I
didn't have problem with the gay catalog
and now I just [ __ ] blew it no guess
who won't be doing a [ __ ] what is it
Avatar whatever the [ __ ] they do it
gives a [ __ ]
what do you want to do ducks something
the duck something about the global
warming with penguins you won't be in
the next Ducks Mighty Duck sequel right
but two computers that want to [ __ ] was
that another one
short circuit is that what it's called
is that the one from the 80s no the one
that was like recent I saw it Nia loved
it it was uh there was like a computer
and he liked the other computer and then
there was fat people who couldn't walk I
never seen that one it was so fat they
were dragging each other around that's
on some of the ideas that get shot down
and I just heard that that just didn't I
mean just on the rough sketch of what
you said is just like what a computer
liked him and he liked her and fat
people
oh hang on let me finish doing this is
skeptical as I was
that I would uh ever
finding six what skeptical as I as I was
that I would ever find I guess find
success not finding I have always
prepared for the eventual
accordingly
what knowing the transition from amateur
to professional would be arduous dude
you should have been a [ __ ] writer
um however it has been surprising to
find that the most difficult aspect of
the job is not what was expected such as
meeting deadlines working with
established professionals satisfying my
editor et cetera but something I hadn't
much accounted for uh what is causing me
anxiety and filling me with Dread is
that in a few months time a relatively
large swath of Americans will be in
possession of my work pawing and
prodding casting judgment upon it I
imagine it akin to witnessing my child
stillborn
Jesus Christ dude
certainly a dramatic comparison but my
paranoia is rampant my question to you
is what is your advice for dealing with
artistic growth in the public eye not
limited to the negative I imagine the
positive side can have as many drawbacks
uh thanks and go [ __ ] yourself dude this
is a very contemporary question this is
this is one of the dangers of the
internet now long setup where oh yeah
absolutely well he's a passionate thing
here plus half the reason they write him
this long is because they want to hear
me struggle sure they think I love it
they think I don't know that I don't
know what they're doing slip by
um
yeah I would just say when you put it
out there you just um don't go on
Twitter
don't do like if it's doing well that's
all you need to worry about okay
um and even then I'll you all all you
can really worry about is you did what
you thought was awesome
and people either like it or they don't
and [ __ ] them you move on to the next
thing but you really gotta develop a
tough skin for this type of thing and
um
you know there's going to be a couple
people no matter what you do
I mean I went to the Sistine Chapel and
made fun of it and look at me I can't
even [ __ ] draw a goddamn stick figure
so I mean just take that with a grain of
salt that that's gonna happen like I got
a special coming out this week you know
I'll get some good [ __ ] I'll get some
bad [ __ ] but you know I take all of it
like I don't give a [ __ ]
as long as people keep coming out to my
shows I know that there's people that
don't like what I do I know there's the
people that think I stink I know that
there's people that you know might not
like
whatever and it's just a part of it and
if you're going if you're gonna put your
[ __ ] out there which you want to do
because you want to make a name for
yourself or you wouldn't be pursuing
this um you're just gonna have to
develop that tough skin so give yourself
time to develop it if somebody says
something negative because I know you're
still going to read them because it's
your first one and if they say something
negative and it makes you feel bad
um that's completely normal but
afterwards kind of examine the fact that
you let somebody who you don't even know
what their background is they probably
can't draw at all and you allowed them
to ruin a part of your day that you're
never going to get back and uh you start
looking at that way eventually you'll
get over with go get over it right what
would you say well I would say uh he's a
cartoon guy right like a cartoon
stripper yes he is the thing about that
is if you're a little leery about how it
gets accepted in the public eye or
whatever I cool thing about being a
cartoon strip is you can kind of go
under a ghost name or a written name and
you can kind of put your thing out there
like you said put it out there you don't
have to go to Twitter or anything see
how people receive it and then when the
criticism dues comes like they are going
to come because that's just what people
do and especially in this in a thread
comment uh reality that we live in no
matter what's posted or what's shown um
you can kind of maybe at least protect
yourself a little bit uh you know
knowing that it's a ghost name or a
written name or a pen name and you can
kind of try to accept it uh that way and
feel like well I can step into this
person now and own it as me yeah no
matter what you make [ __ ] all over
they're gonna [ __ ] all over it and just
no matter what you [ __ ] do some
people they're not even serious they're
doing that trolling thing which is
really the easiest [ __ ] thing to do
oh yeah but it's fun as hell it's fun to
do that I understand why people do it so
all right uh last one here is we're
winding down uh 24 year old virgin
dear Billy blue balls I am a 24 year old
man who has somehow never pulled the
trigger I've had plenty of chances but
whether it has been the condom breaking
whiskey disc whiskey dick he's trying to
write or just straight nerves I've never
been able to pull it off I've recently
moved into a new apartment and this fact
is is uh keeps slapping me in the face
I'm having to make up sexual encounters
to tell my friends and hope they never
run into that girl and hope it comes up
in conversation well dude if you're
going to make a chick up don't be have
it be somebody real
um he said I set up profiles on Plenty
of Fish and Tinder but it comes
uh these guys like this must be yeah as
a young guy so I don't know what the
[ __ ] that means but I haven't had much
luck and don't really want to [ __ ] a
bunch of fat chicks I almost broke down
and got a hooker online don't do that
called the number never set an
appointment but the fear of getting in
trouble slash feeling like a loser
stopped me plus dude you're gonna you're
gonna get you're gonna get a disease
that way dude you're gonna go from
having this [ __ ] pristine dick
to it's just gonna look like [ __ ]
roadkill you know so after one at Batman
you don't want to do that
you gotta ease into the hookers people
um anyways I don't have David
Joe c-h-o-e and do you know what that is
c-h-o-e no idea who does he play for
dude never heard of him I don't have
David's show type money to go uh on a
traveling [ __ ] Venture and I'm getting
sick of failed attempts whether they are
online or in person I feel as if it is
affecting my confidence with women and
my life in general I realize that
whoever I bang first I'm going to be
awful that has influenced who I would
approach because I wanted to spare
myself the embarrassment of the
potential situation what do you think is
the best thing to do uh keep trying to
get normal girls or just go on the back
page of hotel six spending spree no from
one Irish guy from Mass to another love
to stand up for uh podcast and thanks to
the advice go [ __ ] yourself
um
I would say you got to get out in front
of this son
you got to come clean
like you're so ashamed over something
you shouldn't be ashamed of
um that this is causing you to do
something you don't want to do which is
go [ __ ] a hooker you don't want to do
that that's going to be horrific you
could get arrested you could get a
disease you could get disease and get
arrested it could turn out to be a dude
it could be a zillion [ __ ] things
traumatic
that could happen for you so what I
would do is just
just [ __ ] you know so stupid but just
be yourself this is you your 24 year old
virgin I don't know why it hasn't
happened you put it out there it's
actually a confident [ __ ] move don't
tell it to some blabbermouth [ __ ]
just approach a woman that you actually
are attracted to and like you actually
like who she is that's the one you want
to be with okay
you don't want to be with some [ __ ]
you know I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
doing you want to leave some cut like
that you know you might be going from a
virgin to uh you know if you get your
first murder in there you know that
seems like one of those things you're a
24 year old virgin you'd accidentally
push it too hard and she'd whack her
head
oh my god get up sure you had a motive
and this guy couldn't never get laid you
know what I mean like and they bring in
the guys breaking you down you never had
sex did you did you took all the other
ones out I heard it yeah you know what I
mean like yeah I want answers exactly
yeah I think be yourself but here's the
thing is I think this guy's a little
concerned about
um like how he's gonna perform too and
what the girls gonna think of him so
that's why he's thinking he's he's in
the hooker realm like it's like they're
paid not to laugh at me you know what I
mean like it's almost like it's sure sex
and I can kind of figure my way out
they're not gonna teach anything either
they're just gonna [ __ ] late right
but he's maybe thinking that that's why
I say the play is you're 24 if you got
some friends or whatever the story is or
wherever you hang out you might like
have a favorite bar or something to do
listen it may sound a little shallow but
if I think if it gets you through what
you're going through which I think I
know what you're going through is you
know find out who like the the like in
your age group because they are are like
the loose girl like without being a
prostitute like the chick that's been
banging some guys around the scene for a
little bit not really no I'm serious
like this is a way to that's the way
he'll get laid this is a way to get a
real person without all that other stuff
still kind of be yourself you can even
he wants to keep the fact that he's a
Virgin Under Wraps that's fine this
girl's not gonna you think a girl's
gonna keep her mouth shut nobody do you
don't even tell her you just go into it
with a little bit of confidence she's
because that's why I say do the [ __ ]
because she's gonna help you figure it
out she's not gonna she's enough of a
kind of the loose girl to just so you're
saying he just sits in a chair takes it
out and goes get on so then I mean she's
got to handle the [ __ ] entry there so
he won't [ __ ] that up he just sits he
that's what you do you go out you buy a
throne at a [ __ ] yard sale right you
get one of those biggie crowns and she
comes over right and you just [ __ ] uh
Herman Munster that's what you sound
like when you're doing that
um Lillian
um no no I I I look well this is the
first thing I do stop being so [ __ ]
hard on yourself and uh it's not that
big a deal it really isn't that big a
deal and if you told your friends
you know if they laugh at you whatever
guys break balls but they're going to
try to help you
they're going to try to [ __ ] help you
out but there's always going to be a
couple of douchebags and who gives a
[ __ ] if they go and they say who cares
half the [ __ ] people you know are 24
not even half most of them you're never
gonna [ __ ] see again exactly that's
why I'm saying take your dick out no I'm
seeing that you know in a perfect world
bill yeah you meet a really nice girl
you are yourself yeah that's a perfect
world it's a movie it's a movie listen
and you're still 24. that's gonna happen
a little later down on the road you're
going to be an experienced confident guy
and you're going to meet the right
person you're going to be able to really
be yourself in this instant to get this
thing out of the way you got it like you
said before you said you got to get out
in front of this thing I say you got to
put it behind you in a sense too because
it's like you got to be able to pick it
up and move on and go to the next you
know get the condom on when you walk
into the box well I'm just saying next
stage you're like I say find the fight
you know start finding out like hanging
out with him a little bit like cute
girls that are just kind of out there
having fun they will hold your hand
through the fun man I'm telling you you
won't even have to tell them that you're
a virgin and guess what at the end of
the day you won't have to tell anybody
you're a virgin because you won't be a
virgin anymore
Jay Law ahead ladies and gentlemen Jay
lawhead will be performing at the
Lorraine Palace Theater December 27th uh
tickets are online if you go to my
website actually you can go to
jasonlawhead.com because the ticket
Link's kind of long there's a banner at
the home page you can click on the
banner it goes right to the site we got
like a a group pack for Holiday pack for
a little discount if you buy like you
know a certain amount but they're 15
bucks a piece it's going to be a great
show December 27th what time 8 P.M
Lorraine Ohio Lorraine Ohio man and it's
the release of my uh debut CD you've
never heard of me which I'm excited
about putting out and putting that
that's awesome behind me too man I am as
excited about that show as I am seeing
what you're going to cook up this year
at the Rose Bowl yeah ribs buddy bison
burgers in the morning uh for like uh
omelets and then the Bison burgers in
during the you know that middle part and
then uh the the feast before kickoff
will be ribs oh it's gonna be
unbelievable and then I got the Cuban
cigar hooked up
all right that's the podcast for this
week uh I hope you guys all had a Happy
Thanksgiving
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast NFL Edition
uh we are previewing week number dude I
can't even believe we're going into week
number 13 of the NFL season dude it's I
remember literally being excited at the
beach that a week from now is week one
and we are less a month less than two
months away from it being over but we're
going in how fast it goes oh my god dude
um we are ready for uh week 13 we're
gonna talk about everything that
happened in um week 12 but first we got
to talk about our great sponsor it's the
BET MGM bed MGM has the best money lines
most current up-to-date money lines that
there is okay how do you get bet MGM if
you listen to the show it's very simple
you download the app you use bonus code
Burr b-u-r-r you'll get a hundred
percent risk-free bet up to a thousand
on your first wager here's how it works
you download the BET MGM app you sign up
when it says do you have a bonus code
you say yes b-u-r-r that's Burr you
deposit uh at least ten dollars and
place your first wager on any game
you'll receive up to a thousand in free
bets
um if your bet loses just make sure use
bonus code Burr b-u-r-r when you sign up
um folks I don't know what to tell you
me and Bill are beside ourselves with
the Monday night special don't know what
to tell you we are we are trying we are
trying we've been close but but we are
we're listen man we're right there I
believe I'm a half a game back right I
went two and two which which makes me 23
24 and one look man
this year dude how difficult this year
has been as far as like
um the Jekyll and Hyde of like I swear
to God 60 of the teams it's just like
who the [ __ ] are you
yeah
um they really got parody to a whole
other level dude my whole Theory last
week of like if you get more than eight
points just take the dog because you're
gonna get that back door cover
[ __ ] unbelievable man I hit the giant
I went one and three I hit the Giants
game on Thanksgiving I'm like all right
man I might go two and two three and one
who knows
and on Sunday I went oh and three the
one [ __ ] game that drove me nuts was
the Rams game I remember who the hell
they were playing
it was like how many points were they
getting the Chiefs and they were playing
the Chiefs they're getting 15 [ __ ]
points
they're down by 16 and it's the classic
the Rams are getting the ball with like
a minute and a half back I'm like all
right Chiefs are going into the prevent
they just gonna give up a touchdown or
at least let them go down and get four
shots at the end zone I got a chance at
the back door cover Paul they were up 16
points in the minute and a half the
[ __ ] corners are like right up on the
[ __ ] line playing defense and I'll
tell you and it worked they had like a
three and out they didn't even get a
[ __ ]
first down and I'm like yeah it's like
well I I can't uh I feel like the Monday
night special anytime we go under it
goes over anytime we go over it goes
under dude Paul right now I am I am a
[ __ ] cornered Gambler in the dark
just swinging wildly trying to catch the
book and he's got those [ __ ] night
vision goggles I'm getting the [ __ ]
kicked out of me
um I feel like every time you've taken
the Giants this year you they've they've
got a win for you right
I haven't taken it much but I feel like
they have yeah yeah like they have
um yeah it's a weird dude I don't know
who the Falcons are I don't know who the
Saints are I don't know who dude this is
just oh the [ __ ] Falcons they had the
goddamn ball they were they gave him the
whole [ __ ] backdoor cover
and dude what would they be doing if
they if they didn't have their Destiny
in their [ __ ] hand do they just throw
a pick or take a [ __ ] sack I should
have known better I love Marcus Mariota
I think he got benched early in his
[ __ ] career the guy's showing that he
can play but good Lord dude the Falcons
are the Bermuda Triangle of the NFL you
go down there you don't know what's good
people just disappear
you know what dude I gotta tell you
something because this is the first time
I ever saw this you know me I'm a
positive I hang on to a player Canal
he's all right he's good when Brett
Favre went to the Vikings dude he's
having a good year Tom Brady no dude
listen there's a Benny Testaverde 43 but
for the first time I saw a guy last week
that I know is done and I mean when I
tell you he's done he's done he made
something first of all he was like
nothing in the first half and then he
did make some passes in the second half
no tank left and I think that's why he
got benched but I think I watch watched
Matt Ryan in his last season it's a
[ __ ] rap dude you just watched it
they were like trying to do he went like
first pass almost pick second pass pick
third pass nobody was there dude Troy
Aikman was like trying to they were just
like yeah you know he's you know well it
was like it was like he slings it he's
not afraid to sling it
and listen Matt Ryan I I would say gr
would you say great career or good
career
but he had a great career where it's
just like dude he played for the Falcons
yeah yeah okay and the guy was really
successful in so much of it is who you
end up with because one of the biggest
curses
in the NFL at least back in the day I
don't know now with the priority but
back in the day is if you were the
number one quarterback prospect coming
into the draft you were gonna go to the
worst team in the league with no
offensive line and you're gonna take
like 10 years of punishment in three
years so that's why a few guys
Elway Eli I think and you know guys
going I'm not I'm not [ __ ] playing
over there let me ask you a question
bill in your memory do you who's the guy
that you remember watching going oh this
is we're not going to see him next year
do you do you remember as far as
quarterback oh what you mean like it's
towards the end of their career like
you're watching them and you're going
yeah dude this is not the same guy I
think he should retire like you're
watching it though like real time you're
watching a game going oh dude that's not
the same guy who would you say I don't
know no quarterback really sticks out I
would say
um
because dude this now you know ever
since the age of like Peds and [ __ ] yeah
like this these guys they start to dip
and then they come back for like three
four years which is just a clear sign
yeah I can tell you this dude you hit 37
and it it you start you're going down
it's a grease till unless you go to the
pharmacy do you want to hear the
somebody's list of top athletes who
should have retired earlier yeah go
ahead oh in football okay well this is
all sports is only like fun but the the
number one and when
is a lot but Michael Jordan
I don't know about that uh Brett Favre
Jerry Rice
um yeah those guys all hung on too long
but I always but guys that were that
great to me
it's like you're you're just their
inability to to retire is also what made
him great so I don't I don't look at it
like Jerry Rice went did Jerry Rice go
to a Super Bowl as a Raider right
you know what's funny is when a guy when
a guy uh what did you say he went to the
Hall of Fame as a Raider no he went to
the Super Bowl as a Raider
which is really [ __ ] which is not
talked about but him and Tim Brown were
Raiders and Rich Gannon was the
quarterback and they went and lost the
Super Bowl am I right yeah I'm right
about that I think
yeah Tampa they lost to Tampa they lost
to Tampa that was when ronday Barber
Tiki's brother was the MVP he was a
defensive back and that was the the Tony
Dungy ring Tony Dungy took over for
Gruden and a lot of people were like all
Gruden grew that team Warren Sapp got a
ring that year
oh yeah I remember when when yeah Gruden
won with the Bucks and they wouldn't
give it up and be like oh yeah that was
Tony dungy's team he goes yeah but he
played his own [ __ ] team oh that's
right it was I I Had It reversed it was
it was Groot and got it and they said it
was dungey's team
yeah which was so stupid
um all right well let's get into week
13. no no no I got one for you okay you
know what's funny is when a guy
starts losing his skills and he starts
getting mad
yeah it's like an old man
um I saw a basketball player do it I
love him too much to say his name
but he just I mean like
oh can we talk about that by the way
dude like the level of [ __ ] cursing
that these guys do when they're clearly
saying the F word
and it's uh I used to think I'm like how
like I watched the end of the USC
um UCLA game and it was a [ __ ] great
game and it was two great quarterbacks
and uh unfortunately the guy I was
rooting for UCLA he threw a pick in the
end he tried to force one in there and
use USC gets the ball back and their
quarterback I think ran for a first down
or something like that in the game ended
dude he took his [ __ ] helmet off dude
and I think he said Every curse word you
could possibly say and the camera's
right on him he just thought yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's what the [ __ ] we do
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
like right on his face and I'm just
sitting there going like this is like
network television
afternoon Network I know and it's like
it's a comic I can't do that
and this guy's sitting there and they're
going like he's excited I mean this is
such a big win for USC and he's going
[ __ ] eat my [ __ ] ass you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
laughs
I mean there's a thing it doesn't offend
me I actually think it's [ __ ]
hilarious
how these kids today anytime they win a
game or do something they act like
they're in 300.
and I always wanted you know what I
actually thought of a funny sketch
was to put one of them back in the day
and have them run for a first down and
then get up and be like
ah and have all those Dick Butkus guys
just look at it uh then on the next play
they're like twisting his foot around
and the rep's not throwing a flag
because it's not illegal you know what's
funny too is like if if if Al bless you
if Al Michaels or like one of those guys
like Brent Musburger when they're
talking very elegantly about the game
and they'll be like wow you know it's a
big third down coming down this and all
of a sudden you just hear a guy go [ __ ]
you and then TV and you know Al
Michael's heard it and he's just like uh
you could tell though they try to like
play it up I just think it's like uh
dude Kevin Garnett every time Kevin
Garnett got an and one close up on his
face Jesus Christ the the best thing
about kg was if he dunked it hard or
made a big shot he backpedaled and you
just always heard a mouth [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] Owens
um
yeah listen you know what here's a guy
here's a guy who got mad at the end of
his career oh yeah Josh Beckett
yes yes Josh Beckett rather than doing
what I saw Pedro do great one develop
another pitch which obviously is a hard
[ __ ] thing to do he got like he got
like Matt and I remember like watching
him because I love Josh Beckett that was
hard to watch Rose just like dude that's
one of the greatest [ __ ] memory that
is one of the greatest things I've heard
somebody say to remember that because he
would get like because he was dominant
and then he wasn't and when he went to
the Marlins he wasn't and when they
would ask him questions he was [ __ ]
bitter dude that's because he didn't
cheat Paul
because he didn't cheat yeah he was like
some other angry guys that I've seen he
would have just done the Peds and then
won another [ __ ] 50 games and gone
over 300 and people would be like oh
should this guy be in the hall
yeah
yeah and I think also coaches I think
coaches when Dennis Green rest his soul
I think Dennis Green passed away but
when Dennis Green goes they didn't they
were who we thought they were and we let
him off the hook when he screamed that
and did that I think that he that was
his going like this was my shot like
this is my this is my last run I didn't
like I didn't like acting like he wasn't
making a [ __ ] point
exactly we knew who the [ __ ] they were
you know what they were he was basically
saying yeah you know lean on your fight
your older brother and you're actually
to the point where you can beat him you
just don't know how to win
so you start winning and it doesn't feel
for me and then they start being good on
you it's like oh yeah this is what I'm
comfortable with that's what he was with
so I thought it was an impassioned
speech and all of that and I hate how
they just uh
anytime a coach loses his [ __ ] they
don't necessarily listen to what he's
saying they just immediately make fun of
him for flipping out and uh you know and
it turns into memes and [ __ ] but I
imagine his imagine his mother at the
dinner table with the son what happened
I heard you almost beat your brother
today what happened he is who I thought
he was Ma and I let him know
um all right well all right let's get
into the gambling actually I actually
looked at the I looked at this five
minutes ago when I grabbed my coffee and
I'm gonna say I like some of these games
I like some of these games I like some
of these lines hey Paul that makes one
of us I hate it this week did you all
right well all right you you lead the
charge dude you lead the charge
somebody's got to beat the book it ain't
gonna be me you know as I was scrolling
and I saw the one game that hit me first
that I really I really like their
chances I'm gonna go it's week 13 so I
do get the first pick right Andrew just
double check okay I'm gonna take
the home Vikings I like the home Vikings
I know they're they're given three
points but you know what the jets are in
disarray with the quarterback they
benched their first round pick they got
this kid Mike White who's good but he's
also now going into a hostile
environment and let's be honest the
might the Vikings are a better team by
three I like that I see if I lose that
game I think it would be a push instead
of a loss there you go taking Vikings
mind I like that too because I think
when the Vikings got smoked by the
Cowboys all of a sudden everybody just
flipped and said they stopped which I
don't think that's the case because the
Cowboys are now not invincible
I like that
God damn it Paul I like that that
goddamn pick ah my God oh my I got like
eight games in front of me right here
that I would put money on it I don't
know which one's gonna pop out at me
um
all right I don't know why why are the
Chiefs only minus two and a half in
Cincinnati I don't understand that I saw
that I didn't get it I think I'm gonna
take that one because I think
you know the Chiefs know how to win I
think they still have enough guys left
from their Super Bowl run I think that
they know that they need to turn it on
this time of year
and uh Bengals are still a little wet
behind the ears and also a little
erratic week to week and I feel like the
Chiefs are just marching towards
you know being the dominant team
especially with Buffalo I don't know
what's going on with those guys in that
defense which has sort of been
underwhelming so I'm gonna take the
Chiefs lay in two and a half Paul going
into Cincinnati I'm gonna say they're
going to lay off those wonderful ribs
that they make in that
incredible City and they're going to
come away
by three I love that picture
that's a great it's one of those picks
where it's like gun to your head that's
what you would take all right look
I
early on I took my Giants and and it was
good for me twice I believe
then I didn't want to touch him against
the Lions because I know my team so
you're talking about something chick you
used to hook up with
it was good for me twice next time
hanging out with her she's just like a
[ __ ] she had like that red wine gray
teeth and stuff you know just
um
but I think that the Giants are have
back to back losses and this is another
division game and it's at home and
they're disrespected the last time the
Giants had a winning record and they're
a dog at home oh that's talked about in
the locker room I'm gonna take my New
York football Giants having to beat the
Washington commanders they're getting
two and a half at home they got to make
a statement and start winning uh so look
it's a big part of their season now
especially to get in the Wild Card I'm
gonna take the Giants plus two and a
half all right I like that I like that
pick all right I'm a little confused
about what if I'm a little confused here
I'm looking for what I'm gonna do next
uh
I don't know I've been betting the
Titans all year and they've just been
good to me and uh I know the Eagles are
a good team I know that they're home
but I just think Tennessee I just like
that organization I like their coach and
they're getting four and a half if it
was three
I'd go Eagles I like the four and a half
um uh Titans obviously have a running
game right that [ __ ] lunatics not
hurt this week is he I don't know
anybody's name anymore Paul I shouldn't
even be doing this um I'm gonna go with
the Tennessee Titans getting four and a
half pull nice little balanced attack
all right I took a favorite now I got a
dog
you know yeah
uh I saw that game and I was like that
yeah that that's a that's that's a tough
line
um hey it's a rough one Paul yeah it's a
rough one okay a game that I find
interesting dude is the Niners and
dolphins that's another line the
Dolphins are good man
the Dolphins what about the 49ers
defense dude good defense does it good
defense Paul Paul verzi does a good
defense still beat a good offense I was
looking at that one too
France got a great offense too dude
um and they got an Italian a quarterback
Paul what are we doing here
I'm gonna take the Miami Dolphins
getting four oh
I know it's a big one it's a big one
hey that's what she said
um look
I could become this is one I could be
completely wrong or hey do you ever
notice when we do this do you ever feel
like you're gonna be right or wrong with
your pick in like the early second
quarter like beginning third quarter
like you get a sense of the game or no
uh no I did get a sense of the game of
the Falcons game when you texted me hey
that Falcons pick looks great I
immediately thought well I just lost
that [ __ ] game
who does that
the game is going on I'm winning my bet
and he texts me hey your Falcons pick
looks great tear up the tickets tear up
the tickets
you gave me the mush on that one okay
I love I love don't even look don't look
don't even look
by the way is there anything funnier
than a horse race better watching the
thing and having the up and down
emotions might be one of the funniest
things I've ever seen it's that it's
just there's a a sadness it's really
being romanticized
degenerate Gambler uh horse and dog
track people there's a [ __ ] sadness
to that dude
because there's a game every day of the
week dude and you only get paid once a
week
uh I don't know dude that Miami one is
my wild card I'm scared of it but go
ahead what do you got I I I'll say this
I think that that's going to be a great
game all right all right that's going to
be a great game I think that that's
gonna uh great offense versus a great
defense and with all these rule changes
Paul and also Paul hey you know
something though they're really saying
that guy that coaches the Dolphins is
like an offensive genius so
I don't I don't you know I know the
49ers yeah
all right oh no no here's why because
they did that and they did that with the
Jets man genius and then that went to
[ __ ] wait a minute wait a minute
whoa don't [ __ ] put him in with the
goddamn New York media
New York media there's a [ __ ] rapper
on the ground that can [ __ ] make that
thing I don't mean like an MC I mean
like a [ __ ] hot dog rapper they can
[ __ ] make that thing look like it's
the greatest thing ever oh the rapper on
the ground I was like who's rapping on
the ground I was wrapping on the ground
is this some new genre Bill don't push
me cause I'm close
um who's your third pick
no I think that what that guy the way
he's using he's not just using uh Tyreek
Hill like okay he's fast sent him out
there he's using his speed to get this
to to [ __ ] not only get the other guy
open to get Tyreke Moore open
ah I watched the whole breakdown on this
[ __ ] thing where they they they do it
they put Tyrique in motion and then he
comes along to their number two receiver
and they're both [ __ ] blazing
and if people don't know what to do
ah okay they find that space Paul they
find that space in the in in one of
those [ __ ] uh I don't know I mean
over my head so I hope my pick is right
I think it's going to be a great game
all right I'm gonna shut the [ __ ] up for
once here all right I'm gonna go with uh
I don't know why Paul what do I do why
do I do the things that I do Paul I'm
gonna take the Lions plus one over the
Jags I think what's his face
uh Jared Goff I think he got a bad
[ __ ] deal out there in uh Los Angeles
I think he's way better than people
think
and I was impressed with them on uh
on
um
Thanksgiving
and then also gonna have all these extra
days off
they're playing the [ __ ] Jaguars
right okay
oh I didn't like that response at all
you know why just because both of those
teams are so weird to me the Jags in
Detroit they could be down 14 and a
third and then you look across the
bottom and it's tied it's just one of
those well let's be honest you don't
like the pizza in either City so it's
just affecting how you look
um
Detroit
um Bill you know there's a game I feel
like Detroit's Pizza is what Chicago
thinks their Pizza is
oh [ __ ] shots fired right there oh yeah
Chicago Pizza it's a pie it's a it's
like a it's like uh it's literally like
a pot you can't eat it by yourself you
can't just go out and get a slice
Detroit style it's like a crispy like a
crispy Sicilian slice but soft I'll tell
you what dude Detroit style pizza that
cross dude oh the crust around it oh
let's be honest dude you bite something
and it crunches it's [ __ ] incredible
when it's you know what I mean
um there's a game tonight bill
oh there is there's a game tonight oh
where's that Paul who's playing tonight
and uh
this is a weird line to me I don't know
why is it only three and a half it's
only three and a half you guys are at
home everything says stay away but part
of me thinks the Bills win I don't know
this is my fourth and final pick correct
Andrew I got the Giants the Vikings the
Dolphins and number four
who's it I'll tell you who I'm done with
I'll tell you who I'm done with I know
who you're done with I'm done with the
Packers and I'm done with the Cults
goodbye you've been you've been done
with the Packers yeah yeah I kind of
like them this week but
that's funny I like the Bears
no this is this is tough dude this is
this is why this week I don't know who
the Rams are getting seven I don't know
what the Texans are I mean
all right
all right dude
I'm gonna do something I'm gonna do
something I don't wanna do
but you know something it's never going
to end
they've won two in a row and it seems
like I don't want to say the ship is
righted just yet
but they're happy they're hugging each
other and they finally feel like they
figured something out this will be the
last time I take them if I get burned
but I am going to take the one point
home favorite
Las Vegas Raiders versus the team that I
said was going to go to the Super Bowl
against the Chargers
okay
why do you keep going back to this
relationship it's it's one point they're
at home and you got back to back wins
one thing I've learned watching these
things behind the scenes stuff is they
say in the NFL after that first couple
wins dude something happens in the
building I'm gonna ride with that and
see
it's one point might as well be a coin
toss I think the Raiders figured
something out you know Paul just to make
it fun this week I'm going to take the
charges
okay I'm just gonna take I didn't even
have that game on the books I don't I
hate when you do that because you're
head to head I hear who
had to happen you're [ __ ] kicking ass
man look at you I had your one like an
assassin this week you got your Jordan
hat on no dude I had one head to head
with you I won this year last year I
think we went head-to-head five times I
think you won four or maybe four five
so uh I know but you know it's something
you ended up winning by a half a game
and I did the same thing last year I had
an emotional response to something and
that week ended up [ __ ] me and last
week I had an emotional response to the
cover to the uh the cover too the
[ __ ] uh prevent defense and I was
trying to prove a point and what happens
when you try to prove a point Paul you
go one and three
um by the way I think going back so
Andrew just so you know our fourth pick
is my Raiders minus one his charge is
plus one
um
I think that prevent [ __ ] because
remember we were talking last week and I
go not all teams do it and you go who
doesn't do it and I know I know that
everybody I bet on last week I think
it's the coaches dude I think the
coaches are the [ __ ] ones that are
like that are like the scared coaches
the coaches that don't [ __ ] I think
it's what do they call it martyball
well Marty but martyball is what the U.S
soccer team did against [ __ ] Iran I
don't know why they by the way let's
talk about that for a second dude did
you watch that game dude I've watched
every minute of every World Cup game and
I'm so by the way the the captain shout
out to Tyler Adams the captain 23 years
old went to high school with his mom she
was a year older and his uncle was in my
grade and this kid is 23 years old he's
the captain he's playing phenomenal
um dude if you watch I watched every
minute we don't we actually if you look
at the shots on goals they couldn't even
touch the [ __ ] ball dude they got
into that scared they got into that
scared thing where I I thought Iran was
gonna score but you can do that in
soccer though
there was a [ __ ] team in the Premier
League Arsenal they used to have they
used to sing one nil Arsenal they go up
one nothing and then they just go into
this [ __ ]
defense that you couldn't beat
it was frustrating as hell to watch
uh dude the last five minutes I was
jumping out of my skin dude I was like
if because because if they tie they're
out and I was like but um I got I got
one for you oh I got one for you I don't
know it'll be I'm bet MGM maybe you
could do a poly pick on Ben and jam I'm
putting out I mean I don't want to jinx
anybody I'm I'm betting that U.S beats
the Netherlands I think we're gonna go
to eight dude I think and here's why
I'll just give you my reasoning that
game Saturday right that game is
Saturday at 10 A.M my time
7 A.M your time dude we played England
who's the number five team in the world
we had way more shots on goal we look
like we [ __ ] if you watch that game even
though it ended in a tie if you watch
that game and you just had to choose who
won I think we clearly won Wales got
that goal late against us dude we look
really really good man can I ask you a
question have we ever beaten England in
the World Cup just in a match
uh Andrew can you could probably figure
that out now but you know I think that
that was the first time we've beaten
them at least in the last that would be
like when we lost to Australia in that
boat race that no one get that no one
also doesn't give a [ __ ] about
in this country hang on I got one I got
one for you Bill what's that
if if by some crazy chance
okay
if all of a sudden
this young U.S men's football team
Football Club
if this football organization if this
men's U.S national team by some crazy
miracle
gets through Netherlands gets to the
eight all of a sudden penalty shots to
win gets to the four and pulled this off
let's just say the United States wins a
World Cup let's say that's gotta that's
bigger than the 1980
do you believe in miracles right no
no okay no because that was amateurs
playing a professional [ __ ] team
okay we were amateurs they didn't have
an NHL over there so they had all their
gretzkies and lemuse
playing against guy too like most of
those guys didn't even have an NHL
career
no no I'm I'm asking because I don't
know but like I was saying like if we
played Brazil or like Ronaldo and only
because people [ __ ] on an American cold
war with Brazil either it's it's it's
completely different Rocky never fought
a guy from Brazil there's a reason for
that
no uh
Rocky's next Nemesis is from Portugal
[Laughter]
I think it would be hilarious if we won
the World Cup the complete lack of
people showing up to the championship
parade
I was joking on my podcast that it was
like a [ __ ] be like a WNBA
Championship parade
that reminded me of the uh uh Espy joke
or we were right whatever I sent one in
or something and said uh after the LA
Kings won the Stanley Cup the streets of
Los Angeles was filled with people
saying what's going on no what happened
oh what happened
um all right bill it's time I hate I
almost feel silly doing it but you know
what time it is can I give you the the
record England USA it's uh all-time
head-to-head uh England has won eight
USA has won two uh there's one draw uh
England has scored a total of 39 goals
USS scored a total of seven in all their
matchups when was the last time we beat
him the 1940s after they went along like
Germany
yes I England
[Music]
um
we came so close when polesic hit that
top bar
I think it's called the crossbar
isn't a crossbar football no
it's a goal post uh 90th June the
crossbar in General on goals is just the
one that's horizontal on top yeah
June of 93 is the only one I could see
it looks like there's only I only see
one
June of 93 is how many years
oh geez dude I gotta tell you this too
we we haven't beaten them since I've
been paying attention
which I don't really pay attention but I
mean I mean
like all right Bill we gotta win people
some money here and you got to do you
know what time I'm gonna put the
pressure on we don't have to [ __ ] do
anything they're big boys and big girls
out there gambling all right
and by the way listen we're [ __ ]
we're getting three quarters of the
[ __ ] pick right so somebody if they
just zig zag here maybe you'll [ __ ]
get it God knows we haven't
all right bill you got to sing the song
though I mean it's not a oh sorry it's
gonna make me have a coughing fit here
all right let the Midnight Special
midnight oh sorry the Monday night
special well that's the song win some
money for you that's the song I'm doing
let the Monday night special
um we're gonna hit once this year
we have the New Orleans Saints going to
Tom Brady's home in Tampa playing the
Bucks it is minus three and a half for
the bucks the under over is 40 and a
half
oh boy
well I think we could say Tommy to throw
one
yep all right definitely that Brady to
throw on that one I would guys that one
I'll
they had a bad week last week let's take
the [ __ ] over let's say Tom throws
one
and uh I don't know
Tom throws one the over
and do you want to give the Saints the
points or do you think the Tampa wins a
game by four oh that's what we say I was
going to say that that that kid uh
Kamara scores one um
for Paul why does that have to be four
why can't it be three
Gundy ahead does Brady beat the division
rival Saints by four in Florida on
Monday night though it's actually it is
Tom's Monday night though
yeah I think he does we had that whole
conversation earlier
about playing too long
oh I don't think he's doing because he
had his best statistical season last
year it's just that they got a new head
coach and they got all this other type
of [ __ ]
and he's dealing with you know by the
way the clock management of the new
coach I don't know if you saw that game
but like he let the time go down and it
was bad dude like he that Todd [ __ ]
blows my mind at the pro level where I
feel like to even get the job
one of the first things you should know
how to do is manage the clock
yeah Matt's kind of like
yeah
you know by the way you got to know how
to yell at an official you know to get
him to maybe give you a call and not get
a [ __ ] technical or thrown out of the
game or a flag or something like that
there's certain just [ __ ] you should
know how to do as a coach
and one of them is manage the clock Paul
Paul that's like you not being able to
get the [ __ ] mic out of the mic stand
what the [ __ ] are we doing
dude did you hear what Jeff Saturday
said when they were like you know a lot
of people are upset that a coach that's
been coaching for years the NFL didn't
get the job and that you were just a
player and you've never had one coaching
job in your life and now you're the head
coach of the Colts and he goes look he
goes you know the one thing that I do
have though is I've just been a
passionate because I've played here and
I've been a passionate fan for many
years of this team and it's like yeah so
have the fat [ __ ] dudes in the upper
deck at Giant Stadium
it's like how about I played the game in
the trenches for 15 years
yeah at that point go to [ __ ] OTB and
get a fight with a headset on one of
those fat bucks no dude come on dude
that guy I'm joking dude no he played he
won a Super Bowl I'm kidding but like it
is funny to be like no I've been around
they won a Super Bowl after they stole
our offense and made the way that we
covered their receivers illegal no
offense no offense to the Colts or their
fans but that was one of the worst
boring super dude that Colts playing Rex
Grossman and Chicago Bears in the rain
was one of the most lackluster Super
Bowls ever it just was dude it was a it
was a rough one okay yeah hey hey just
for shits and giggles but friends
Grossman was the quintessential Chicago
Bear
quarterback draft pick that game was so
bad Andrew tell me who the performance
at halftime was just to see if it puts a
[ __ ] puts a ribbon on it
if it's like [ __ ] bad dude if it's
like Katy Perry like
no offense hey no offense just have who
was it you know uh
but it was oh he likes it he likes it
Bill Andrew likes it was Prince at the
halftime show oh okay oh thank God
Prince saving the [ __ ] day oh that's
right dude he was playing Purple Rain In
The Rain with the purple to the soul
okay okay hey thank God Prince was there
okay
all right guys uh so Monday night
special will be Tampa
to win by four the line's three and a
half we're gonna take Brady to throw one
and we're gonna take over 40 and a half
so 41 points total I think we can do
that they got Camara on the other side
there you go everybody this has been
uh preview NFL preview week for the
anything better podcast
um number 13 going into week 13 just um
go to the uh app store and get the BET
MGM app download it use bonus code bird
put in uh at least ten dollars and
you'll get uh
you'll get what hundred dollars uh that
up to a thousand in free bets right
there's collected during all of that
Paul no no no I'm just making sure I now
you know what it is dude I'm gonna start
I'm gonna start taking the the password
off the iPhone you know it's like every
time I go into my iPhone I got to put a
password it's like you know what I mean
you got to put buttons and stuff and
it's just when was the last time some of
you caught somebody Paul going through
your phone never
um
I'll tell you another thing I don't do
even around people that I love I don't
leave my phone in my jacket no matter
what I do it's there because somebody's
gonna look at it somebody's gonna try to
no nobody knows touching it
um
yeah so there you go I'll download my
phone laying all over the house I
[ __ ] hate the thing yeah
there you go guys download the app b u r
r hope uh for the for the code and um
hopefully we hit with the Monday night
special I kind of like our I like our
chances this week uh there you go we're
out of here we got a puncher's chance
and good luck to you Bill tonight with
your Patriots versus the division rival
bills you too Andrew
the only luck I need is figuring out how
to [ __ ] watch the game
um but they realize the second you put
it on some streaming service that I'm
not gonna find it any guy over 50 is not
finding it
it's on Amazon now yeah oh it's on it
would I literally look at that like a
[ __ ] term paper okay I'll I'll do it
next week
as sad as it is to say whenever I
whenever I order pay-per-view UFC fights
my wife has to make sure because if it
doesn't go through I just go it's not
working and then she comes down and hits
one thing and it's working I do the same
thing
um all right guys good luck week 13. see
you guys next week and remember guys to
bed you got to be 21 years of age or
older to wager in Arizona Colorado DC
Iowa Indiana Kansas Michigan Mississippi
New Jersey New York Nevada Pennsylvania
Tennessee
uh Virginia West Virginia or Wyoming
only new customer offer paid in free
bets visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions uh excludes Michigan
disassociated persons uh please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step for Arizona call
1-800-522-4704 Colorado DC Nevada
Wyoming West Virginia
1-800-270-7117 for confidential help
Michigan
1-800 Gambler in Indiana New Jersey
Pennsylvania and West Virginia
1-800 bets off in Iowa call or text the
Tennessee Red Line
800-889-9789 in Tennessee or call
1-88-77-9696 for Mississippi sports
betting is void in Georgia Hawaii Ohio
and Utah and other states were
prohibited
promotional offers not available in
Nevada
[Applause]